Hey, I'm Ben Shapiro and welcome to a
very special edition of the Rubin report.
Once you replacing another,
joining me today on his new set after 34
glorious days off the grid is the host
of the Rubin report. Dave Ruben,
welcome back and I'm sorry dude
or Shapiro. I feel like I'm
in the twilight zone right
now. Truly. I really do.
I mean, first of all of your hosting my
show, we're on a new set here, new chairs,
new carpet, new tables, new art, do
everything I have. No, I genuinely,
genuinely,
I have no idea what's going on in the
world since August 1st I know one thing
that I found out two days ago because
my dad could not control himself in an
idiotic phone call.
So I know one thing,
I suspect it's a pretty big
thing that that has happened.
I know you have a list of it.
I had a list of 20 things here,
20 things that you missed it during
the last month because as we all know,
one month of time in Trump world is
actually seven years of regular time. So,
but,
but let's talk first about like what it
was like to actually be off the grid for
for 34 days. I do it like once a week,
but you did it for 34 straight days,
which has got to be both wonderful.
And also now you have to feel like you
just jumped directly into assessed pool
of crap. Well I haven't jumped
in yet. I think we're about to,
I will assure you is this
cesspool of crap right there.
I mean, first of all,
I just, I feel great.
I genuinely mean that.
Like
guys, I think because I'm going
to go, I know I'm going to just,
I'm going with a little bit of
like a runway here and then you're,
we're going to, you know, take
us off into the ditch. But like,
just in terms of like how I feel
as a human being right now, I,
my mind feels clear. I
feel good. I feel positive.
I feel very grateful for the things that
I have this last month. I mean really,
I don't know that I heard the
word Trump more than three times.
Truly. Like you know how every
conversation now that anyone has anywhere,
and I'm not even just talking about the
world we live in, but just everywhere.
People talk about Trump all the time
to talk about politics all the time.
Everyone thinks world war three starting
tomorrow or the Russians are just like
this endless like rang core monster of
insanity and I didn't have any of it for
a month.
I'm telling you that every interaction
that I had with the human being since
August 1st and today's
September 4th was good.
It was decent weather.
I was talking to cashiers or waitresses
or the girl at the hardware store who
I've told you about who every time
at this local hardware store I go to,
she always goes, oh Dave, I love you,
but I really love that Ben Shapiro.
It turns out that the hardware store is
closing and I said to her the other day,
I said, well, good luck in whatever
you're going to do. And she was like, ah,
don't worry about it.
I'm going to Grad school now.
And it was just like talking to different
people and I tried to do all that
anyway and not be online all the time
and not focus on the hate and all that
monstrosity. But I just, I feel
freaking clear man. I really do.
And I'm psyched that we, that we did
all these changes around here and Yep.
Beautiful.
Thank you for coming in and doing this.
[inaudible] the guy who read the
game of Thrones books and then was waiting
for the rest of the world to catch up
on the red wedding. Yeah, exactly.
You're going to get ready my friend.
God, this is, this is going to be there.
Oh, it's, it's, it's pretty wild.
But first I want to ask you about
like how hard was it to actually,
you know,
shut yourself off to a,
to actually put that phone in that safe
because even for me, ideal once a week,
but you know, the rest of the week I
find myself, the phone's in my pocket.
I'm checking Twitter almost
as a reflex at this point.
How hard was it to actually
put it down for a month?
Well,
first off,
I want to give a little credit to the
orthodox Jews out there because perhaps
this Shabbat thing has, has, well I
guess it's not just the orthodox thing,
but has figured something out with
getting off technologies. Well done guy,
because I actually get a score one
for God, right? Because look, I do,
I try to do the weekends off in general,
but I struggle with it sometimes in a lot
of times if I'm on the road, you know,
I've been on the road with Peterson
for the last couple of months.
So like if I'm on the road, it's like,
yeah, what else am I going to be doing?
You know, I can visit some tourist
stuff and had some dinners or whatever,
but I'm feeling around it. Um, you know,
I did this thing last month, last year,
last August, and it was,
it was basically, you know,
the first couple of days ago going
into your pocket all the time.
Like literally you feel your phone there
or you get those phantom vibrations,
all of that stuff and you
feel like you need it.
Or you know what I noticed was weird.
Like if you're just,
if I was just waiting for somebody,
like when's the last time you just
like waited on a corner for somebody,
you automatically look at your phone.
Yup.
You don't just stand
there even for 10 seconds.
You don't just stand there and kind of
like look around or people watch you or
just think or look at
the sky or any of that.
You literally just go to your phone
that moment. So that sort of thing.
I noticed that in the moments of
quiet where I was doing nothing.
If I was in between things you plan.
Even if I was taking a shit,
I'm on my phone.
Usually I am and I suspect you are
interior but everyone's doing it.
But guess what? I was pooping phone
free and then you have moments to think.
I mean I know this
sounds suiting bay pooping,
phone free and I'm sorry that we did this.
Yeah.
Well it just look,
even this like avoiding
the news in general is also
work because what I realized
is when you're off this
for a little while,
we are slammed with this nonsense
all the time and when I say nonsense,
I don't mean the important things that
I think you and I and a bunch of other
people are trying to talk about and trying
to deal with the difficult questions
of the day and I'm sure we're
going to get into some of that,
but just the endless 24 hour news cycle
of just dribble that keeps everybody
angry at each other and and confused about
truth and distracted and clicking and
all that.
Even avoiding CNN when you're not looking
at television and don't have a phone
was hard. CNN is wherever a
muted television is, period.
It's everywhere. Airports, it's
at the gym, it's at the local.
You're going to go to a burger joint.
It's play in or a diner or whatever.
Everywhere I go,
I went to get my car tuned up.
It's playing in the lobby there and I had
to literally avoid watching, you know,
cause there everything's breaking news
and none of it's really breaking news.
They're actually breaking news. But you
know, you, I had to actually avoid that.
So I was at the gym and they have all
these TVs up there and I had to literally
do cardio with my head down because
I didn't even want to avoid that.
So we're just like slammed
with all of this stuff.
And I think when you step away from it
a little bit that I know you're very
excited to get me back in,
but when you step away from a little bit,
it does give you a little perspective.
And I always also thinking about
things like, I mean as I said,
every interaction I had was positive.
Like this idea that we live in this
country of like endlessly racist,
evil people. When you're out there
actually talking to real people,
you know, and again I do this, I tried
to do as much of this as I can normally,
but with then we're also in this digital
thing. It's like, it's not like that.
People are good. People want
the same thing. It's like I,
I so fundamentally believe that. And I,
I've always believed that, but I really,
really believe it.
Yeah.
Now I used to think that the hope
for the country rested and you know,
the 40% of the population
that was following this
stuff closely and the more I
viewed this stuff,
now I'm starting to think that the future
of the country rest with the 60% who
really do not follow this stuff closely.
Well that's the thing. It's
like, well what do you do then?
Because part of me literally like a week
ago and I knew I was about to come back,
I was like, man, like why ever come
back, I'll go find something else to do.
I wanted to be in the NBA. Like fine. He
goes, you know, and not that you, I mean,
you know how much, like you really
know how much I love this. And like,
I think what we're doing is so important
and I think I'm a better person now and
all this stuff.
And,
and after being on tour with Peterson
for months where for months I,
I've been performing in front of thousands
of people every night and it's this
great love fest of people who are getting
their lives together and disagree on
what the marginal political issues are.
But like all of that greatness and
it's like I could see because of,
because of all the evil that is out there.
And when I say you blamed me just like
the hate and all the people that want to
keep you clicking and angry and distracted
and, and fighting with everybody,
I could see why a lot of good people
that we really need would just be like,
I'm out all together. I'm never going to
post again. I'm never going to read this.
I'm going, you know, and,
and that's a real problem because then
if we push out all the good people,
now you have the middle majority that's
endlessly just being slammed by one side.
Dare I say that's partly why I think this
whole intellectual, dark web thing has,
has taken root and has some meaning now.
It's because I think for all of our
differences, which we've discussed,
many of them including abortion in
death penalty and a whole bunch of other
things,
it's like we're trying to basically
live in the same society together and,
and not hate each other for
whatever those differences are.
And as I said to you last time you were,
you were sitting here,
it's like on something like abortion where
we disagree. It's like, you know what?
Hopefully for the next
50 years we'll do this.
And then maybe when I'm
a little older than you,
so I'm 92 and where are you
going to be in 50 years?
Uh,
I'll be 84
and you're 84 like maybe one of us will
have moved one of us one way or another
in order to eight. And I know
you're looking at me going, Reuben,
you're not going to move me.
But you know,
who knows what happens
over the course of time.
But the only thing that will allow them,
and we're looking at like, I don't
know if I'd be alive in 50 faith. No,
that's why I would recommend a
digital detox. I'm telling you,
I feel better by hartfields better.
My head feels better.
I know this is a little corny,
but I,
I genuinely do feel that way and it was
also just making me want to reinvest in
everything I'm doing.
That's why we have a new set now and
a new website and all this. It's like,
I really like,
I believe in this thing and I want to
sort of take now these pieces that I just
absorbed of the world over the last
month and now apply them to all the stuff
that we talk about all the time.
Shapiro here. Okay, here we go.
Let's go to work my friend.
And this was the, uh,
you were promised at Jami of News Shalvey
so, all right, so I know of the story.
Yeah. What, what was the last thing
that you saw on the news? Okay.
So the last thing that I know of was
the day that I got off the shutdown
everything.
The last thing that I heard was that
the New York Times hired that writer,
the the female Asian writer at, apparently
she had tweeted a lot of anti white.
Okay. So I know nothing free for
all I know she doesn't have a job.
Now she does have a job. She has a bigger
job than ever. She has a show on CNN,
she has a job,
she hasn't got back to see it at other
times and there was blow back on anyone
who suggested that she was racist,
that a lot of the left came out and
said that she couldn't be racist because
racism is actually discrimination
plus power. Nonsense.
She still has a job. Yeah,
and that's totally okay.
Let's be very clear on this because I
am familiar with and clear minded right
now racism is hating someone
because of their race.
It has nothing to do with power.
You can be black and hate white people
and you're a racist and you can be white
and hate Asian people in you're racist.
And you can be Asian and hate
Latino people just because
of their skin color and
you are racist. No, not
according to the New York Times.
The New York Times is wrong. That's
the end of that story. Meanwhile,
Alex Jones got banned from Facebook,
so she still has a job there.
So I saw a bunch of the tweets, the
only one of the, the one tweet, look,
I've joked, you know, before
I sort of woke up politically,
I used to joke about Republicans being
an old white man a lot and whatever.
And it was just stupid jokes.
And I,
I don't regret them because it's
just part of what made me me sort of,
I think they're stupid
and they were short,
shortsighted and maybe not
very informed at that time.
But what the one tweet that I did see,
and I think this might've been quite
literally the last thing I saw before I
shut down was there was,
um,
something about she like hated,
she loves making old white
people cry or something.
And I thought that that kind of strikes,
uh,
that kind of strikes me in a different
way. You know what I mean? You know,
so there was a big argument
that took place over Sara Zhong,
not just over her actual comments,
but over whether she should be fired
based on Twitter mobbing. So there was a,
there's a big sort of discussion that
happened about social media mobbing and
people piling on and whether people ought
to be fired and lose their jobs over
old stuff that they've tweeted.
And of course that followed in the
wake of the James Gunn and stuff.
But you were still here for those gems
gotten from guardians of the galaxy.
You Remember Brian?
So that happened just as I was
getting along.
Exactly. So James Gunn getting
guardians of the galaxy director,
he lost his job because there were some
old tweets of his that were, that were,
you know, making jokes about
pedophilia and such. Right.
So there's a lot of talk about Twitter
mobbing and then the terrorists young
thing happened and that was a Twitter mob.
And so there was a lot of
talk about whether you're not,
whether she should have been hired,
which is a separate conversation,
but whether people should lose their
jobs based on people digging up crap you
did 10 years ago and now coming after you.
So let me get this straight. So, so she
still has a job despite all that stuff.
Roseanne Barr does not have a job.
Correct. Because of one tweet,
which I actually do believe that Roseanne
didn't know that Valerie Jarret was
black and Rosa. That's crazy person.
Roseanne is what she, yes. Right.
So describe described crazy
person. That's right. Right.
Well it depends which person you're
talking to. The right people are there.
But so, but I just want to understand
all this. If you're trying,
cause when you stepped away,
it does seem a little odd.
So Rosanne sends this one tweet,
which she apologized for us that
she didn't know that she was black.
There's no reason to think that
Roseanne has a history of racism.
She's always been fighting for
lefty causes forever actually.
So she gets fired from the number one
stay calm in the country. Then this girl,
sorry, one more time. Okay.
Sherry. John, cause I'm out
of it a little bit. She, yeah,
she maintains her job. She maintains
her job and gun. His gun got fired.
Yeah, gun got fired. There was
an attempt to bring him back,
but that kind of failed.
It turns out there were pictures of
him at some like joke pedophilia themed
party with the women who were over age,
but the rest of school children in such.
So Disney was not going
to maintain his job. So
I don't even know what to do with
all that. But I think partly I guess,
and I guess this is from stepping away
for a little bit, it's just this sort of,
when we apply the standard answer that
that I think that's what's driving people
crazy.
Probably mostly conservatives and people
on the right because it seems to always
weigh much more heavily on you.
Please, I will can't unlearn one of
the facets of this that he ministers.
So Candace Owens then tweeted out
everything Sara Zhang had tweeted,
but with reversing the races and Twitter
immediately suspended her before they
realized what she was doing.
No. Should they move Candace?
Yeah, that was good. Okay.
So meanwhile,
Alex Jones gets banned from Facebook and
iTunes and there's a coordinated hit on
Alex Jones between,
I believe it was Facebook and Youtube
and iTunes to demonetize him and deny him
platforms. Wow. All in the
same day. All on the same day.
I think it was a with me within 48 hours.
So it's fun to break this stuff
to you and a, and wow, wait,
so justi monetizing him? Uh, no.
I think youtube actually took
down his entire channel. Oh Wow.
Wait 10 Alex Jones is not on Youtube. Uh,
I believe so. I haven't checked recently,
but yes, that was the story. Uh, and
they all did this on the same day,
within 48 hours. So it was, it was,
it was obviously a coordinated hit,
obviously coordinated hit. Wow. And
so they, they took him down. Uh,
they gave various reasons why,
but they didn't give any
sort of objective reason why.
So it wasn't like some of them said it
was because he had threatened violence in
the past.
Some of them said that it was because
he had said on palatable things in the
past,
but there was no clear standard.
And so there are a lot of folks
on the right saying, listen,
even if you don't like Alex Jones,
you know when people,
I said those and I know Alex Jones Fan,
I mean threatened me personally. Yeah.
But you got to at least articulate a
clear standard for how you're going to
police the boundaries here.
Otherwise everybody ends up in the,
in the throw them overboard category
because these boundaries are randomly
expanding. So yeah, Alex Jones got
hit. He hasn't really paid, um,
any series monetary price cause he has
alternative distribution channels and
he's,
and he's insulated himself
nice things.
You get a massive hit.
Oh yeah. No, I mean it's, it's, you
know, obviously took it seriously.
Although his listenership I'm sure is
up because people are tuning in because
square,
right.
Let you stand on this
now because you know,
for the last two years I've
been saying relentless Lee,
the answer is not government intervention.
I just don't think that the government
policing Facebook and Youtube and Twitter
and all those things that
that will help anything.
I think it would muck
things up even worse.
It would give more power to just
middle management bureaucrats. And,
and since the government is
not very good at anything,
I don't think it would be very good at.
Yeah.
So president Trump has, this is one
of the other stories, president Trump,
his sort of jumped into this and
suggested, right. I'm still president.
He's still president. Oh, okay.
Congratulations to you back in time.
You didn't miss it and miss
the big finale. Oh, does it?
I didn't Miss Number 20 there.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. But uh, he,
he was suggesting regulations.
Some other Republicans have
sort of put it out there.
I don't agree with regulation,
but I do think that we're going to have
to come up with either some market based
solutions or we're going to have to,
you know,
recognize and force Facebook
and Twitter to be treated as um,
as not platforms, but as,
as the actual publishers,
which is the real controversy
over over Facebook.
Is it a platform or is it a publisher
to lake over at daily wire, which I run,
if we print something that is
liable as we will be sued. Yeah.
Illegally live will be sued.
If Facebook puts up in article
by us that is libelous,
then Facebook doesn't get sued. It's
a platform. If they're not policing,
what can we put up in what cannot? At
what point do you start saying, well,
you're just like the daily wire or the
New York Times or CNN and you start
getting policed that way. I think that
Facebook either needs to demonstrate,
you know,
what it's objective standards are or
start getting treated like any other
publisher in the space.
Because if they're going to police,
then they're policemen.
Yeah. So you're right and
you're being consistent with,
I think what your other
views are in this department,
but there's this piece of me that it's
like, did we miss the boat in a weird way,
now that I've stepped away for a bit,
like with the amount of people that are
watching Rogan and watching you and me
and the rest of the and Sam
and everybody else is like,
why don't we have a network already?
You're going to be like,
I know there's endless discussions about
it. We've had discussions about it.
We've met with people I,
but it's almost like there's
something that almost is like,
there's some other weird thing here,
like the amount of power that these
companies have now amassed over us is
bizarre and it's like if, if the crew of
us can't figure out how to do it, who,
who can figure out how to do it.
I don't know what the answer to that is,
but it does. I'm a little,
I mean this is where,
of course I'm for the market dictating
it so it's like, yeah, it's on the last,
yeah, you're like, let's get cracking.
Because at the end of the day, look,
forget Jones, he's irrelevant I
think in the scheme of whatever,
but it's like at the end of
the day you get rid of him.
Well now you've moved the bar,
it gets a little,
there's a lot of people that think that
you are an extremist all by the way.
So I do want to mention this real quick.
So one of the, there were a couple,
two or three little things that were
rattling in my head about current while I
was away and one of them was a few
weeks before I went offline was the mark
Duplass thing.
Right you and for some reason it was
really sticking with me while I was gone
because for those that don't remember
Mark Duplass, basically mark Duplass,
who's a friend of mine who's been on
the show who is a lefty in an extremely
decent human being,
a nice guy.
I had breakfast with him like two
weeks before the tweet was sent out.
He has a really nice guy.
He's trying to bridge
by the office. We spend an hour and a
half together. You seem like a nice guy.
Yeah.
See He's just a nice guy
trying to do some nice work.
He mostly does those comedy stuff. So, uh,
he tweeted out basically that Benji,
Piero isn't the devil.
That's basically what [inaudible]
intentions and it was a nice guy. Yeah,
that's it. And, and basically that
people should take a look at you, right?
Yeah.
If you're looking for somebody who's
honest on the other side of the aisle or
something.
Yeah. So this happened a little
bit before I went off the grid,
but he deleted it then
tweeted at now apology.
So the mob comes after him.
He then tweets this thing about how he
doesn't stand for homophobic or racist
views, implying basically that your race
or races through all the usual nonsense.
And I don't want to make this about
mark cause I think he's a good guy and I
don't know what pressure came to bear
on him either from studios or the mob.
And it scares people.
You don't want to lose your job.
Hit him when he deleted
the tweet and I said,
I totally understand why you do that.
I get it.
And then the next morning he
tweeted out that was [inaudible],
right.
Good Times.
That was really rattling in my
head because as I've stepped away,
it's like, I know, and this
goes to what I said earlier,
we need these middle decent people who
are willing to figure some things out.
And it's like they basically took him
out. And when I say they, it's like,
who knows what that is? Is it just
the mob? Is it, you know, studios,
I don't know exactly what it is,
but like those are the types
of people that we need.
And this is why I would link
it back to the Alex Jones.
They're shredding the Overton window. The
Overton window will continue to shrink.
It's like, all right, we get wordy Jones
one day and no one wants to defend Joan.
So fine. Okay, he's gone.
But they'll keep moving it and they'll
keep saying that Shapiro's this or
Ruben's that or whatever it is.
And eventually,
eventually we'll be on the
outside of that thing too.
And that's very much on my mind for sure.
Okay. So in other news, uh,
Alexander Ocozzio Cortez continues
to sort of gain steam as this.
So she's gaining steam. She continues
to gain sort of public promise.
You made a bunch of gas while you're out.
Yeah.
She suggested the middle
class doesn't exist anymore.
She suggested that
everybody in the country,
even though the economic
statistics are good,
that's only because nobody has
two jobs. Yeah. Okay. And uh,
and then there was a bit of a tiff because
I offered to host her on my show or
debate her. Oh, right.
And I offered to drop 10,000 bucks for
the privilege and she suggested I was cat
calling her.
So that was,
so that was her response was that I
was cat calling her and then in their
mainstream editorials in the New York
Times suggesting that it was sexist for me
to offer. Are you kidding? No. No. Sounds
good. Times. Not, not a major story,
but drove the new cycle for
probably a couple of days. Um,
so you, I know you well enough.
You offered to debate her.
Was he offered to debate who
are either one? Either one,
whichever one you want. I said, I'm
happy to have you on the Sunday special.
Would you have been on for a discussion
I've had on a bunch of people.
I disagree with Aidan. Sam
On that special. Yeah, I've
had on Eric on that special,
I've had an a bunch of people with whom
I disagree on a variety of issues on
that special. Yeah, I and a, and I said,
I'll give $10,000 to charity or to
your campaign or the super pack,
whatever you want. Uh, and or we can do
debate, whichever format you choose a,
and she tweeted back that she,
that there's no reason for her to respond
to this is the equivalent of of men
cat calling women,
which is like,
I don't know how they can't
go home and it's equivalent
of men treating women equally.
That's what it is, right?
You're not viewing her,
you're not going,
I want to talk to this woman because
she's a woman so I can destroy her.
You're going,
this is somebody who I disagree with or
at least I want to explore their ideas a
little bit more. We'll do
it either way. You want
also cat calling and me. Yeah.
Weird, weird moves. So that,
so that was kind of a minor story and I
don't want to hover on that one too much
cause to somebody
it does go to the sort of a a
bigger thing that these people are,
are put out there with their ideas.
That all sound good. All of this.
I mean this is another thing that
was rattling in my brain a lot,
but all of this leftists stuff
that I used to buy your for gays,
your board this year for poor people,
it's all bullshit.
It's all epic,
endless horse shit.
I mean that really is all
it is. You're not for gays,
you're, you know what I mean?
It doesn't even make sense to say you're
for gays because gays think differently
that it's incredible. You'll never
believe this. You get 10 gays in a room.
They probably have 12 different opinions.
And to say that you're,
you're for black people or have
four black conservatives. I mean,
I know you know this stuff, but
again, when you step away from it,
it's like be in a weird way. And
I hate, I really hate to do this,
but in a weird way. Uh, Catherine verbal,
seeing who's the last guest I had on, uh,
last week, but we had taped it at the end
of June. Uh, July. She's an educator in,
in England.
She had taught in the inner cities for
a long time and basically realized that
all these guilty liberals were just
kept throwing money at things that were
keeping minorities oppressed.
And she said something that really hit me,
and this is the last thing that I did
before I left. She was basically saying,
these people are the racists,
they're the modern racist.
And they're always screaming that we're
all the races and I don't want to become
men, so I don't want to sit
here and be like, Oh, you know,
these lefties are all the
racist by, by, by, but the, the,
the racist ideas of the day are not coming
from conservatives and Libertarians.
They're really not. And they're certainly
not coming from classical liberals.
They are coming from the progressive's
that actually is just true.
It just is. Okay. Shapiro,
let's go.
Okay.
So let's do a bunch of Mueller updates
because there was a bunch of news
motherland, but you've already
told me Trump is still president.
So friends and storm the castle.
Yeah, right, right. Oh the, the, the,
the latest generic congressional
ballot has Republican's down,
I think it was the NBC ballot today
has now 18. So do you buy that?
I buy the Republicans are down.
I don't,
I don't think I've done 18 but I think
the Republicans have some serious
problems in the midterms. The,
the, the, I mean Democrats,
a lot of motivation to turn out and they
have since the election because they
feel like if they had turned out,
they would want in the last election,
which is true. So that's, that's been
building. So here's what happened.
I'm gonna lump these all together
cause there's a lot. Okay.
So Peter Struck that fire and over
at the, over at the, uh, at the FBI.
So Peter Struck,
has everyone recalls,
is the guy who was texting
with his paramour Elisa page.
And leading the Russia investigation
and the Hillary investigation,
and he was fired for essentially
sullying the reputation of the FBI.
So he ended up being fired.
President Trump provoked security
clearances for people like John Brennan,
former CIA director. There
were rumors that was gonna
happen. Yeah, so he did that.
He, he revoked his security clearance.
So what do you make of that?
Because I kind of,
I'm not a,
I'm not an intelligence analyst
at the highest level is here,
but the idea that that Brennan and some
of these guys were taking classified
information and clearly leaking it to,
to the media or the Times or whatever.
Like forget what the information was.
Forget the Trump is president.
If anyone was president and former
officials who still have clearance,
which is also a little unclear to me.
Why is a former official
would clear rights. I mean,
I guess the basic ideas that inform our
official, if I go to you for advice,
I need to be asked to be able
to ask you about that stuff.
And it's still a crime if you leak
classified information to the press,
even if you no longer worked for the
government that said [inaudible] yeah,
there, there shouldn't be. In my opinion,
there shouldn't be like a blanket security
clearance you get to maintain after
you leave office.
It seems silly to me.
So who else was there
anyone else reporting?
I'm sure Brendan was probably the biggest.
Brennan was the biggest one.
He threatened to do it to Komi who I
think no longer has clearance and a bunch
of other,
basically what it looked like was it
coordinated political hit by Trump because
Trump then went on Twitter and said like,
everybody I hate should no
longer have a security clearance,
and two people said
this is misuse of power,
which of course president Trump doing
everything in the dumbest possible way.
It sort of is, but that's Ed. Should
these people have security clearances?
Probably not. That was the minor
news in this, in this area.
That's huge in a certain
respect but crazy.
Here's the major news in the
major news is that Michael Kahn,
the President's forum personal attorney,
pled guilty to eight different crimes
including violation of campaign finance
law. And in that plea of
guilty for violation of
campaign finance all at the red
wedding part,
he suggested that the president of the
United States ordered him to violate
campaign finance law.
So ordered him before he was president.
So just so the,
so here's what happened.
He goes to pay off the stormy Daniels
via basically David Pecker over the
national enquirer.
The idea was that this was a campaign
finance contribution that he,
he had bought the story of stormy Daniels
from the national enquirer in order to
silence it,
Pecker gone bought storming Daniel's
story and then team Trump buys the story
from David Pecker Reimburses Pecker for
the story. Keep it quiet. Money was that.
So it was Michael Cohen's money.
So it looks like a,
it looks like a campaign contribution.
And then Trump backfills the amount of
money that Cohen paid over the course of
coming months.
Now,
the question is whether Trump knew that
he was violating campaign finance law
when he did that. Right. So in other
words, there are two ways he could have,
just legally speaking,
there are two ways that he could
have avoided this being a campaign.
Finance violations could flat out written
the check directly and then he would
have had to report it as a
campaign expenditure. Presumably.
Can you write it? Why campaign
expenditure? Why couldn't
you have just read it?
Let me check. So he can know, he
can read, he can write a check,
but he has to report that to the FEC.
Right.
Or he can have Michael Cohen
write a track. Um, well he,
he would have to have,
he would have to do it personally or
he'd have to show that he basically used
Colin is a pass through and
then reporting to the FCC.
But there was no report to the FEC.
Right.
So basically the idea was that they found
a back channel to pay her off just so
it wouldn't be reported a
week before the election.
And so the idea is that he was essentially
avoiding the reporting of the stormy
Daniels single week before the
election by paying off a porn star.
That's an in Michael.
Colin was saying that Trump knew all of
this and Trump ordered all of this. Yeah,
and that's why he did all of this.
So how
are we supposed to get
any truth out of this?
This is the type of thing where it's
like, again, stepping away, it's like,
all right,
we can do all the little legal loopholes,
the little minutia and look back on two
years ago and who did this and that,
but it's like Michael,
Colin probably wants to save his butt
now from certain amount of jail time,
right? He's going to do whatever he can,
obviously to throw Trump under the bus.
I have no doubt that Trump probably did
some things out more out of just like
provato and stupidity.
Then like intention,
like do you think he really was like the
crime that they're going to get Trump
on? Was that a $250,000 pay
out to a porn star? Like,
how stupid is this whole thing?
Right?
So there are two ways in which Trump
could defend himself when he could say,
listen, I path ladies all the time. So
this isn't a campaign expenditure at all.
Yeah. This is just me paying
off ladies who we know.
Is there any history of Michael Cohen
doing this for him before? So there's a,
there's a history of Michael and
kind of threatening people before,
but we haven't seen evidence that he's
like paid off a bunch of ladies before.
Yeah.
And the other thing that,
that Trump theoretically could do to
avoid all of this is you could say, well,
Michael cones the lawyer, I didn't tell
him to violate campaign finance law.
It's his job to make sure that I'm in
compliance with campaign finance law.
I'm an idiot. Yeah. So what do I know
about campaign finance law? I just said,
Michael, go, go settle this
thing up. I mean, that's the
Hillary email excuse. Right,
right, right, right, right.
I'm an idiot. And it's not
implausible. Right? Yeah. That's,
that's a plausible defense that said,
he is personal lawyer is testifying
in open court that Trump told them to
violate campaign finance law.
Does that mean Trump gets prosecuted?
Nobody's again prosecute the former
president and you can't prosecute the
current president of the United States
just legally speaking in all likelihood.
But will that be ground
zero for impeachment charge?
I'm sure that it will be the same day
that happened by the way, because yes,
we're all immediately show the same
day that happened. Paul Manafort,
his former campaign manager also
pled guilty to eight felonies.
None of them having to
do with campaign Trump,
but having to do with former campaign
finance violations in representing the
Ukrainian government and
all of this kind of stuff.
And then Trump starts tweeting about how
Manafort's a good guy because he kept
his mouth shut, which is because
president Trump has diarrhea of the,
of the Twitter.
Well first off,
it's a wait.
So Cohen's going in there and saying
Trump told him to violate campfire can be
mindless. I mean that sounds actually
insane. So if that's actually true,
like if Trump actually sat him
down, I was like, here's the check,
let's violate some campaign finance. Like
now we're veering into like, like true.
Is that
possible? It's, it's, that sounds
to me, it depends on the bananas,
but it depends how much plausible
deniability you need. Right? Right.
If Trump said, here's a check
for $130,000, go settle this up.
And Colin said to him, what we need
to report that to the FTC and said,
well let's do cash. Right? And then,
then, then you've got a problem. But yeah,
we have to see what that looks like and
it hasn't been taken that level yet.
The SDNY is still checking into that.
And what are you,
so guy that's doing your show every,
yeah, talking about this stuff every day.
I know you researched the early,
all of that.
How you find the ability to
talk about the ins and outs.
Honestly,
without,
without giving enough room where people
are just going to guess on all of these
[inaudible] some of that nuance that's
not going to be put on CNN and on CNN.
It's he violated campaign finance law.
This is a, this is a federal violation.
He should go to jail.
And the answer is,
well that depends on the credibility
of cone. It depends on Trump's defense.
It depends on a lot of stuff.
Trump doesn't help himself because he
goes on Twitter and just says shit. Right.
I mean that's his thing. But I have
not seen a Trump tweet in a month.
Good for your dirty. For us. That's,
that's a, that's a daily relief. I'm sure.
34 fucking damn.
Well in get ready man.
Cause there's some more comments up there.
So that was the big story because now
that I'm like how old is that story or
that this two weeks old. So it's like,
is it already running out of steam?
I mean everything kind of like them.
Although you know,
maybe it's contributing to the
congressional ballot for example,
because it feels like there's a level of
corruption that is being exacerbated by
another political story,
which is to Republican Congress.
People are being prosecuted for corruption
right now. Duncan hunter down in,
so cal in San Diego,
he's being also prosecuted for looking
like he basically took a bunch of
campaign finance,
the campaign funds and use
them on personal expenditures
and Chris Collins over
in New York who these were the first
two congressional candidate who backed
Trump and Collins came forth and uh,
and supposedly was engaged in
some sort of insider trading deal.
So both of them are now going to
be prosecuted by the sessions DOJ,
which is like president Trump's attack.
Jeff sessions at the DOJ
and literally this morning,
tweet out that or last night tweet
out that that Jeff sessions is killing
Republican congressional chances by
indicting Republican Congress paypal.
So that's all, what's the president?
He has his right to free speech.
He's going to end up probably
screwing himself over with
all of that. Like when I'm
hearing this, it's like, man,
this is all just a great reason to
ultimately be libertarian. Like not,
it seems like none of this works,
right? None of this actually works.
Like if it all worked,
if there was a slim trim operating
government that didn't have too much power
and could just move things on the margin
and not try to redistribute and all of
these things,
it's like,
and it worked and it wasn't always the
old government does is investigate itself.
All it does is throw money at things.
Like it doesn't do anything.
So all of these things, as you're
telling me, I know these are important,
relevant things and when I fully dive
back in like six months, they may not be,
and then two weeks,
they may not be because,
but at least understanding the issues
behind them are important. Like this, this
general thing of like, Oh,
this guy campaign finance,
this guy that this is all they do,
this is all they do.
And if you think Democrats are somehow
better than Republicans, you're wrong.
They're all doing it together.
Oh,
oh, I'm sorry. I'm sort of grouping these
into political and then we'll do some.
And then there was a bunch of
cultural stuff that's already
happened. So, yeah, uh,
other political stuff. The cabinet hearing
is happening literally as we speak.
Co Right now for the Democrats tried to
shut down the hearing from the beginning
by calling for an adjournment
until they can read the document.
Even the though they've already come
out and said they're not voting for
Cavenaugh.
Linda Sarsour got arrested because she
showed up and started yelling at a,
at Cavenaugh and at the Republicans.
And so it kind of devolved into the
spectacle. We all knew that that would be,
you know, in, in the spirit
of my 34 days off the grid.
I'm not gonna say a word about Linda.
So good for you dude. That is, Ooh,
that is some inner peace.
Or where do we pause though?
So there's nothing they can do to
stop cabinet. No, you're right.
So that's going to happen. You
know, you can, for the record,
people can find this video somewhere.
But when I was on TYT way back when and,
and Harry Reid use the nuclear option, and
I was still progressive, lefty liberal,
blah, blah, blah, uh, I said, this
is a bad move. This is a bad move.
You do not want to give this kind of
power cause it'll be used against ESL
in a bad move. It was. So there, there are
two anti Trump books that have come out.
The first was from Omarosa Manigault
the media went nuts over this. She,
she had recordings.
She,
she'd taken her cell phone into like
throughout the west wing and recorded a
bunch of conversations with pretty much
everyone. Is that illegal? Um, maybe,
yeah, maybe there was nothing
classified on the recordings. Okay.
It's basically she had nothing to
sell and she sold whatever she had,
but it was nonstop on Cable News for
24 hours a day for a week. Uh, and uh,
maybe two weeks we're shooting to get
him saying, and then he, and then he,
and then he tweeted out
that that Amarosa was fired.
Nica Doug and what is something like that?
And once he called her daughter
better than it's improving grammar.
But when once called their
dog then it turned into,
is Trump a racist because he called her
a dog even though he was called half of
humanity members of the canine species.
So yeah.
So we enjoy two weeks of hours.
Amount of dog is actually an upgrade
over what I think about as humans at the
moment. Yeah, that's exactly right.
And then Bob Woodward's book comes out
this week and there were a bunch of sort
of typical trumpy and stories,
John Kelly saying this place is miserable,
the work and James Madis saying Trump
is basically a nut who wanted to uh,
pull completely out of South Korea and
asked for preemptive military options
against North Korea and
various, and, and uh,
I think it was Gary Cohn,
like sneaking documents off of from Steph.
So he wouldn't sign them.
And Trump now notice to all the things
that you would expect in the Trump White
House. And so all that's
coming out and Woodward's book,
so expect Trump to tweet
about that a lot this week.
And then we get to some of the cultural
issues. So at the Vma is bunch of stars.
Bash Trump. No shock there.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
You're telling me Hollywood people at an
awards show, we're anti Trump. I know.
Shocker. That was a big one.
Then this changes every pet.
Now I Asia Argento is
a leader in the me too.
Movement was implicated in a,
in her own me to scandal.
So there's a 17 year old boy who had
one plate son in a movie, I guess,
and when he was 17 and
she was 36, 38, I believe,
they went to a hotel
rooms. She stepped him, uh,
and a a parent and which is statutory rape
in the state of California. And He, uh,
and he said that basically
been intimidated into it
and she was hit with this me
too. Stuff also. And then Rose
McGowan came out and said,
we should wait until
all the evidence is in,
which provided all sorts of fodder
for people who say, you know,
maybe we ought to wait for
all the evidence to come in.
So it's interesting. Yeah.
Now that it's turning on on its own
people and now we should wait. Right?
Like Trudeau was like, we have to
believe all women. Then it came for him.
Now we have to wait. It comes from one of
them. We two people, now we have to wait.
So this is bizarre. So that happens.
And, and uh, sorry, sewer this,
she was part of me too.
So this is, this is it.
Yeah.
There's also a story with mentioning in
New York University professor who was
like a performance
artist who is a lesbian,
but she was accused of sexually
harassing a gay man. Uh,
and it's relatively credible.
A lesbian was sexually harassing a game.
She's not a very good lesbian. I think
that cheese there, there've been several.
Yeah, exactly. She'd bet it bad at the
lesbianisms. So yeah, it's so that, that,
and the entire academy came
out to defender of course,
because she's on the left and that's
the way this works. Um, let's see.
How was the lesbian sexually
harassing a game? I mean,
she was sending him sexual
messages. I mean, they have
the text messages. So again,
not good at the lesbian. I think how
stupid this whole thing is. I mean, look,
of course you got to
get the bad guys though.
The Harvey Weinsteins of course the people
that genuinely do the bad things that
you have to get them.
But the thing that we're creating here
where people are going to be afraid of
their own shadows. And you know, we're in
la here. I have a friend who's been in,
in uh, the battle, want to give away
too much, who's been in the Biz on the,
on the other side of the
camera for a long time,
who's a white male in his
probably late fifties.
He's done extremely good
work for a long time.
He's working on a million TV shows that,
you know, well, he's, now, you know,
the way it works with these shows is you
usually work a season or two and then
you move on to something else.
Or there's huge gaps in between seasons
or what were some times you just work
for a studio and they throw you
in all these different places.
He's telling me now that he's being
told by executives that as a white male,
as a straight white male,
that basically he should either start
looking for other work or just don't
expect to work anymore.
I mean think how actually dangerous
that is like dangerous people who have,
this is a good,
decent man who has worked his whole life,
who was an extremely professional,
competent person.
But even if he was completely incompetent,
right.
You should not hire and bring
competence but not higher. No,
don't not hire him because
Henry Cavill,
I mean I think this is before you left,
you remember Henry Cavill
said about dating they,
I was having that he's
only going to date women.
He knows because he's afraid that he's
going to get caught in a me too situation
just because he's rich and famous and
he got killed for that and I don't blame
him for that. I mean, honestly
I can't blame somebody.
Like if you're famous and
you have money to check,
like the pence rule works well
for, for everybody, right? Yeah.
Pence role like this it,
yeah.
Again, Susan harassing me. But
one other thing on this, you know,
they also don't realize how backwards
is actually gonna work because,
so for example, I was just telling you,
we, we just hired a new full time here.
So I have a new assistant, Helen, who's
wonderful. And when we were hiring,
it did pop in my brain for a second.
But I would not want to hire a gay man.
I don't want to be,
not because I'm going to harass them,
I'm not going to harass them.
But why would I hire someone who might
one day turn on me and that'd be like
Dave harassed me. Now I happen to
be gay. So it seems that I made,
if I was gonna harass someone,
it would be a gay man. Right.
But I guess it could be a straight man
to or whatever. But it's like, you know,
so in a weird way and
well, my mom, it was him. I know.
It's like you come up with a
working woman and she say, I mean,
she literally worked, all my dad stayed
home. And I remember when I was young,
she said, if ever you have an assistant
hire like a blue haired old lady. Yeah.
Specifically if you're saying this like
20 years, that's better way looking for.
All right. So let's see what else happened
while you were out? Oh, well, okay.
So this was, this was a big
controversy. So Molly Tibbits, uh,
was a 20 year old Iowan
student at University of Iowa
and she was kidnapped and
murdered by a guy who turned
out to be an illegal immigrant.
And this became a major cost celeb because
president Trump commented about it,
talking specifically about border policy.
A lot of people on the right and jumped
on it perfectly about where was this?
I was in Iowa. Okay. And the,
and the left suggesting of course
they had nothing to do with illegal
immigration.
It was bad to talk about it.
We should never talk about
this sort of thing. You know,
the same left that says every
time there's a mass shooting,
we have to talk about gun control.
Now that you say when it comes to this,
you can't talk about illegal immigration.
President Trump tweeted
incessantly about it.
He cut a bunch of videos like from the
White House lawn and talking about it.
And this became kind of political fodder.
The family said like,
we don't want any part of this,
please don't politicize it.
She was on the left for families
on the left. Um, and uh,
it turned into a bit of a Brouhaha.
Yeah. So where are we at
with this now? Like, hmm.
I mean the investigation at
the guy has been arrested,
he's gonna go to jail presumably.
Uh,
but the sort of battle is less over
what happened in the case. And Moreover,
the politicization of
particular situations.
Like should we be talking about broad
based policy based on individual
circumstances? Uh, is it cynical to do
so? When is it appropriate to do so?
So it sort of generated that
conversation. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean this is one of
the ones where it's like,
this is exactly why I do this show to
talk about ideas and not every little
instance of a thing that
happens. Now, of course this,
this sounds absolutely horrific,
but the way,
like one thing that I really don't miss
after being away is like the three days
that everyone cares
and then we don't care.
Net neutrality is going to destroy the
world. We scream about it for three days,
then we forget about
children being separated.
We scream about it for days and
it's also like everyone's screaming,
not doing all the people that are,
even the people that are getting 20,000
retweets on all the things that they're
tweeting out. It's like, do, are you
doing anything about it? Now I get it.
It's important to share your
thoughts and to talk. Um,
but one of the things that I really want
to do over the course of the next year
is figuring out how do we put some of
this stuff into action because all we do
is go from one crisis to another.
We pick this,
it gets politicized by Trump
for immigration purposes.
It gets politicized over the other guys
for open borders or whatever it is.
And it's like nothing better
after that. Actually, we just,
we just kicked the can down the
road to hell like that. That Ah,
so we have a couple more kind of minor
ones and then there are a couple major
ones to finish up with. Okay.
But on the other minor ones,
Ron Desantis candidate in Florida, so
he won his gubernatorial primary. Okay.
But the guy who ran against him,
uh,
if could one that primary
on the democratic side is
going to be Andrew Gillum,
uh,
who's a black guy.
And when desantis laid an interview very
early on talking about how Gilliam was
a good candidate who had out debated
folks, uh, and he said, you know,
we have a good economy now.
We don't need the guy who's a socialist.
Cause Gillum is very far
to the left. Yeah. Element.
He says we don't need somebody who's a
socialist to come into and sort of monkey
things up for the state of Florida.
And this became a 48 hour
new cycle in which the,
this was accused of being a racist for
using the phrase monkey it up in regards
to socialism,
screwing with the capitalist economy.
But he'd use the phrase monkey as a
verb and therefore he was obviously race
baiting and,
and dog whistling to the evil racist too.
Now we're gonna realize
Andrew Gillum is a black,
right, so allow me play this simple
son to my Jewish friend here. Um,
is there any evidence that he's an
actual racist beyond this common? Okay,
so this is like, remember when Howard
Cosell, it's a little before our time,
but Howard Cosell got fired I think by
CBS news because during a football game,
even though he was the thought of really
is the greatest sports broadcast or a
regeneration, he said, well,
there was a, uh, a blah,
it happened to be a black football player.
I like, uh, a running back or a, um,
I think it was a running back,
jumped over a guy and he
said something about like,
he's monkeying over him
or something like that.
And everyone started calling him racist.
Now this is well before our days of now,
everybody's a racist and he
got fired because of that.
It turned out that that's what he
called his grandchildren all the time.
If I'm remembering the story correctly,
he was always saying, oh, your monkeys,
your jumping all over each other and blah,
blah blah.
So this thing about a word and
that if we can get you on a word,
we now know what your whole,
cause it's not all your political ethos
that we know what your whole humanity is,
man. That is, that is so dangerous.
Everyone has mucked up a word every
now and again. And that, you know,
everyone's intentions all the time.
I mean,
this is one of the things that when when,
uh,
Sam Harris was first getting attacked
relentlessly by the left, it was like,
they always would go after the way he,
it would be a toe.
He said that word that way. Or if we
said this word, but you know, you,
if you would have put a comma
there and it's like, man, you guys,
you want to live in a world where we will
all be afraid to speak because we will
all get to the point where, I mean,
again, it gets back to where we started,
but all the good people will check out.
You will never want to have a
political conversation with anyone.
The the areas for us to just be human.
I know you've talked about this
a little bit to just be, okay.
It's why I can't watch
sports center anymore
so we can get to this story. See,
right. Here's the big sports story.
So yesterday go,
Nike released its new ad campaign,
the 30 year anniversary of just do it.
It's face Colin Kaepernick and it
slogan and believe in something,
even if it means sacrificing everything,
Hashtag just do it.
So he's the new fee. He hasn't played in
the NFL for two years. Yeah, he is. Uh,
he obviously is famous for,
for kneeling, for the flag,
but apparently he sacrificed
everything. He's, uh,
he's going to get multimillions of dollars
in his own line of clothes, uh, in,
in the Nike brand is of course is
create a great consternation. So that's,
that's the big story.
The last 24 hours.
I mean, does this just prove, and I think
a few other people, I think, um, uh,
what's his name? Oh Man, I'm blanking.
I'll get, I'll get in a second. Um, that,
that this social justice thing just ruins
everything. Like it really did ruin, uh,
ESPN. Yup. And that every time they
travel. Yeah. I'm sorry, clay traffic.
That's really how removed
I am. One second. I can't
remember friend's name. Um,
that he just ruins everything that,
that you're handing out sportsman of
the year awards to Caitlyn Jenner and
you're doing all of these things in the
idea that you're being tolerant and good
and you're actually doing nothing that
has anything to do with what your mission
statement is. What is Nike's mission
statement? It's to put shoes and I guess,
you know, sports shirts on people so they
can be the best athletes they can be.
And I'm not saying they should be
completely a political like they should.
And again,
they can do whatever.
Well, it's a capitalist. I
mean it's a capitalist move.
And if you look at the statistics,
either work does this water,
this whole drive. First of all,
it's viral marketing. Second of all,
Nielsen shows that the people who are
most likely to engage in viral marketing
on behalf of brands are actually black
folks in the United States. Yeah.
And I did 44% more likely,
I think according to Nielsen and black
folks in the United States are also
significantly more likely to be buying
clothing as a then then nonwhite folks in
the United States according to a study
from University of Chicago, like clothing,
like expensive clothing. Okay. Per
per income level or income level.
Is there's an interesting something
to talk about their, yeah, they,
they've done studies on, it's really
interesting. Yeah. And uh, you know,
is that a legacy of,
of one of the theories on that is that
it's a legacy of if you can't afford to
show how rich you are
buying an expensive cars,
did you buy an expensive pair of shoes?
It's 300 bucks as opposed to $35,000,
for example. Um, but it's, but
there's, there's a lot there.
And obviously in terms of
disproportionate sports,
watching a young black men watch a lot
more sports than people of other races.
So it makes a fair bit of marketing sense.
But the funny part is the left falling
into the trap of now backing a massive
international company. Yeah. Right.
That is most famous for running
sweatshops in Asia. It's a capital,
it's a really, again,
that's basically the story,
but it's also obviously happening
because Trump's president right now,
this happened two years ago,
if Hillary Clinton or president,
they would not be doing
this with Colin Kaepernick.
Yeah. It's so, it's so interesting because
so last night it was my last night,
right.
And I have,
I now you're sad. Right. And
I'm gonna want to miss my hope.
I hope we've almost
sufficiently ruined your life,
I think. I think you have chance
to ruin it a little bit. No,
but this is what it's all about. Right?
This is why I got off the [inaudible].
Right. This is why I want to
do this with you. But, but,
so the only thing that I did do,
so it's not that I watch no TV,
but I watch movies or
watch Netflix or whatever.
So last night I watched, um, Avengers,
infinity war. I hadn't seen it before.
I thought the movie was
spectacular basically.
I'm sure you've written up probably,
you've probably written a critique of it.
I don't want to go too far into that,
but my only critique wise,
we all know they're not dead. So that's
exactly right. Yeah. It's like no,
Spiderman didn't just die, but okay.
Black Panther, their $1 billion. Right.
So for property investment completely
right, but putting that aside,
I thought it was a pretty great movie
in the way they could link everything
together. The way I link this back to
what we're talking about right now is,
so mark Ruffalo, who plays the hulk in it,
he's a huge lefty, progressive, whatever,
and he's babbling on politics all the
time and on Twitter and whatever. And I,
you know,
I don't like attacking people,
so I don't really want
to make this about him,
but I think he's a pretty
bad actor in general.
Like I find him very
irritating as the hulk.
I thought Edward Norton was a lot better
in the, in the previous incarnation,
but after being away from
everything for a while,
watching him knowing that here's this
guy that like really like politically I
just think is just so annoying and gets
all these retweets on like stupid stuff
and just share as all these what I
think are really bad ideas and whatever.
And of course he can do it,
but like I was, every scene
that he was in, I was like,
Ugh, like it actually kind
of like I love you. Like,
and then David said something which was
interesting. He was like, he's like,
you know, actors, of course
they can do whatever they want,
but it's like if these guys would just
shut up and you didn't know anything
about them, then they'd be doing
their craft properly. You know, like,
and I think there's probably
like people that do that,
that really avoiding the studio
theory for literally decades.
Let's keep that personal life away from
the papers and just the only thing you
see on the screen is the
person on the screen. Yeah.
Or some of them could be
more famous for some like,
like a Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie.
Like there's like a,
there's like a separate area.
You see how his career like took kitchen
ups and downs because of Brad Pitt oily
stuff and now with jelly and all this,
right.
But like these old button but that's more
about their relationships and whatever.
So that's one thing. But these overtly
political people all the time, especially,
you know, I haven't thought about
any of these people in a long time,
but a lot of the comedians that I used
to like that have now gone off the deep
end.
Uh,
politically it's like you guys have ruined
what I thought of your comedy because
of the way you act and behave all
the time. Hey Lucy Kay's back.
No shit getting crap for it and
really wait. What do you mean back?
Like he performed stand up club.
Okay,
well that that would be the natural
way to start. And how did it go?
He got a standing o but people
on the left were very, very,
very upset because he's not allowed to
come back yet because he hasn't served
his proper penance. Wow. So, so what,
so for a guy like you, so conservative,
I know obviously the actions that he did,
I'm sure you find
reprehensible and all that,
but I know you do believe in forgiveness
and I also think that there are levels
of reprehensible. So I think that
what he did is pretty reprehensible.
But what he did is not in the Harvey
Weinstein category of reprehensible from,
from what I can see.
Right.
So when you argue then that a guy
like Harvey Weinstein, there's no,
I know he's probably not getting
[inaudible] actual rapists.
Nobody's watching actual rape
against the Lucy Kay right there.
They're arguing that he brought women
into his room and then jacked off in front
of them and then people
associate with say jacked off,
but you want to say fuck on
camera. That's, that's your policy.
And then I loosen virtually
all my policies, put him on
your show, it's your show.
So I curse a little bit. I was like,
shit on your shot, you want to say fuck,
you'll say shit. And it's
policy. Right. Exactly.
It's like it's like network TV.
So it's uh,
but uh,
yeah,
I think that in that if there's
a market for him to come back,
there's a market for him to come back.
I mean that's,
that's my general feeling for this.
And if people want to sue
him than they should to him.
And if people want to like, this is how,
this is why we have a system of torts.
This is why we have a system. I mean, he
apologized for it. Presumably these women,
if they think that they can find evidence
that they were actively denied jobs
because of the Lucy Kay, they can see,
let me go funny. Right, exactly. Yeah.
But this idea that we're going to put
people into kind of excommunication until
they come back and then we, again, it's
this variable excommunication right?
If you're,
if you're Mel Gibson,
it's a certain amount of time and
if it's a certain amount of time,
can we used the kits like eight
months and for Mel Gibson,
it's like eight years and then eventually
you come back and daddy's home or
something. But is it, but I find all,
I have decent medic fields by the way.
Yeah.
Okay.
But there's something interesting there
because it's like if you don't like
Louis Ck, let's say you don't like him as
like, if you don't like him as a comic,
don't go to shows.
I like them as a person.
Don't go to shows if you don't like
what he did. Don't go to his show.
It don't appear. Don't give him two
drinks and the cover charge, all that.
Just don't do it.
But this is so fundamentally why I
believe that live and let live is the only
way to actually have a functioning
society that all you can do is defend our
ability to be different. That's basically
it, because otherwise it should,
the man never be allowed to
work again. I mean, they,
they say a lot of people say yes, right.
So shoot his wife be allowed to work,
should his children, you know what
I mean? It's like, all right, this,
this is sort of like this
wind is repentance actually
take place because Bill
Clinton is still held in wide as team
for doing a lot worse than, than Louis c.
K that's the crazy, well they did until
we'll get to that. Here's it. So there's,
we have three more headlines, so you're
good. Okay. So headline number one, uh,
is a Risa Franklin died. So that was a
oh really? Yes. That was a big story.
And she had a huge funeral. Uh, it
was a 10 hour funeral, I believe.
Something like that.
It was really insane.
And they just got like every great singer
to a bunch of singers in there. And uh,
the, the kind of headline, the,
the politically oriented headlines,
Al Sharpton got up and bash
Trump and then there was a,
and then Bill Clinton was sitting
on stage next to, in order to his,
he had been to his right. So it was Jesse
Jackson, Al Sharpton. Louis Farrakhan.
Ah, Shit. Yeah. Sitting, sitting
next to all three of them.
So that was one Clinton related headline.
The other Clinton related
headline was more humorous,
which was Clinton who is a dirty old man.
It was a dirty old man when
he was a dirty young man. Uh,
Ariana Grande's saying and
when she came up, yeah,
there's video of him legitimately
checking her out like up and down,
full on, smiling, giggling,
like, like really going after it.
I need find you somebody who looks at you
the way Bill Clinton looks like. Okay.
So let's, let's pause on that one. Cause
we all know Bill Clinton likes women.
Let's just pause on that.
Let's go to the other ones.
Forget Jesse Jackson obviously and
forget Al Sharpton. I have whatever,
forget that they're both both
antisemites but the lesser amount Korean
antisemites they're,
you know,
I think Jews have learned
one thing over the millennia.
It's kind of like you got to pick the big
anti Semite to deal with good whatever.
But like what he was on to see two or
three seats away from Louis Farrakhan.
Yeah. After this is to, I mean only
it was only two or three months ago.
Those insane tweets about Jews
being the devil and all that.
Yeah, man. So he was it. So you use
there and then that was juxtaposed with,
wait, wait, wait, did, was
there any, so of course
conservative media called him out.
Was there anything nobody else cared,
so nothing.
He probably didn't even make it on NBC
nightly news. Not as far as I know it was,
it was sort of just seen as
part of the thing. You know,
they're all the funerals together.
This is the bullshit that people can't
take anymore. This double standard,
epic nonsense that every time a
Trump supporter does something,
everyone on the right should
apologize or whatever.
And that this type of bullshit
the ex president sits with.
What I would argue is the, probably the
foremost, I was going to say preeminent,
the Anti Semite threats. So
that's probably to a dance, right?
But like legitimately like a
disgusting human being who it's by,
by choosing to group up any group of
people in a specific way is the very
definition of prejudice
and racism and all that.
This is what the left is supposed to
be against. This is their whole thing.
But that's what was going on.
So that was just,
what was it that happened on the same
day as the other big story was that John
Mccain died. So that was, I'm
sure the one that you heard.
Okay,
so this is the one that,
I didn't know this until about two days
ago and I was on the phone with my dad
and I said, I said, you know,
we were talking about being
off the grid and I said,
you know, and I have, I don't know
anything. And he was as if he just like,
I don't know what has happened is healthy
and just see, but he goes, but you know,
John Mccain died and I was like,
so they,
but did you know about [inaudible]
as you know? So I know, I know nothing
other than he does. So first off,
I don't even know when he died.
They said justify or, sure. Two
weeks, a week and a half ago. We can
only die to Saturday before last. Okay.
So [inaudible] Sabbath and, and
that was the news. So sorry,
he passed away. Uh, president
Trump obviously not a fan.
And the first thing that it's a Trump
didn't issue any official statement for
two days. And then he, the,
the basic rule of thumb is that when
a sitting senator dies, you lower the,
the flags to half staff until the
person is actually buried. Uh,
Trump did the statutory minimum.
He lowered the flag for 24 hours,
and then he raised it back up again.
All the other federal flags were lower,
but you could see a picture over the
White House of the flag back up at full
staff. And then at the Washington
monument, which can see behind it,
you see all of them down at half staff.
He then reversed himself rate,
lowered the flag again,
issued a statement. And then
at Mccain's funeral, uh,
he was not invited because
Mccain didn't horn in there,
which I can't really blame McCain for
that. And then at the funeral did,
George W spoke, Obama
spoke, Megan Mccain spoke,
all three of them took shots of Trump. So
Megan Mccain, so Megan Mccain said, uh,
we didn't need to make
America great again.
America is already great
and kind of really went hard
after Trump. Wow. And then,
uh,
Obama got up and he said,
know our country was about all these
things here we can have the American creed
and we can,
and we're all part of the same America
and taking pretty obvious mail shots at
Trump. And then Bush did some of the
same sort of stuff. Wow. All right.
So that was it.
So that was yesterday or something,
a couple of things there.
First I find the flag thing.
I mean this is the tight look,
you know,
I think I've been pretty freaking fair
on Trump and I get a ton of shit for it.
I think you've been pretty fair on him.
You get a ton of ship port,
this type of thing.
Like this flag thing like that.
It's just like the non is childish.
That's just the child is nonsense that
looks like this should not be, it's your,
should not be. This is,
this is ridiculous. So let's
just move past that one.
That's it. First off, just quickly on
Megan Mccain, you know, I gotta tell you,
I know Megan A. Little bit. Yeah,
we've met a couple of times and I,
you know, there's a, there's a clip of
her about it probably about six years ago,
if not more at this point on real
time. Did you ever see this where, um,
she says something, she's in, she
gets in an argument. Paul Begala, uh,
is he a democratic strategists are
seeing it, yes. Is on the other side.
And they get into an
argument and she says, Oh,
you're just attacking me because I'm
young and I don't know everything about
World War II or something. He's like, I
wasn't alive during the French revolution,
but I know about that. And it gets
huge applause and it's a great line.
And it's like you can't use
your excuse of, um, if you're,
if you're a pundit or a whatever, then
be upon it. You can't. The second that,
you know, it gets hot in the kitchen,
you can't be like, well, I'm young,
I'm not supposed to be here. So I,
that's why I was very unimpressed.
That was the first time I probably
ever saw her publicly and I was very
unimpressed with her.
I've gotten to know her a little bit and
I'd watched some clips on the view and
my mom keeps calling me and telling
me that she's seen conservative.
And I gotta tell you,
I'm very impressed by her.
Actually.
I'm very nation.
I used to be very much at odds and
in the last I'd say year and a half,
we become good at least friends.
Yeah. I'm glad to hear that.
That's because of this. I mean,
I think the cheese shifted. Yeah.
We've all shifted since we were young,
but I think that juice, she's shifted too,
so,
yeah.
Wait, let me ask you anything. So, uh,
I assume that the day he died
that there was the endless,
like people are dancing on his grave now.
Yeah.
So then that there was a,
there was some of that,
but mostly the left was praising him
because he was the antitrust throws it.
So after spending most of his
life crapping all over him, right.
The guy when he was racist, when he ran
for president and incompetent and old,
you know, and right, exactly.
Then he was a great hero because he was
an anti Trump and so his entire life was
defined by the fact that he
and Trump didn't get along.
So there was a lot of that, uh, you
know, my own take on this was that the,
the funeral, well, I understand
Meghan Mccain's, a grieving daughter.
She had stayed over, she wants,
but that said, is it a smell?
Let's say that you actively want
to undercut president Trump.
Let's say that that's actually your goal.
Your goal at this funeral is
that you want to, is that you,
you don't like what Trump stands
for and you want to undercut him.
Almost the worst thing you can
do is get George Shelby Bush,
Barack Obama and Megan Mccain
up there bashing Trump.
And the reason for that is because the,
there is this,
what Trump is a response to is a sense
that there are a bunch of elites who get
together in back rooms and party with
each other and then they pretend to
disagree with each other for the cameras.
But in reality the crew,
which is kind of true,
right?
But in reality they're back slapping each
other and they're all best friends and
are civil and we all get along and and
then are kind of the commoners out here
where like, wait a second, these
issues actually matter to me.
Why do I care about your golf club?
I don't care about George h
w being friends with Clinton.
I want to know like who wins this
political argument because it affects me,
right? I don't care about
like how you guys get along.
And so it was this feeling like there a
video that was going around to George w
handing Michelle Obama a piece
of candy. And I was like, well,
this is what politics used to be, and
I just kept thinking, no, it didn't.
I'm old enough to remember when
Barack Obama was labeling George W.
Bush essentially a war criminal,
and so you're going to do this whole,
Trump is a departure from everything
that politics has ever been.
It just felt really disingenuous.
Not because the criticism of Trump was,
was uncalled for because I
think some of it is called for,
but because it was creating this image
of politics that didn't exist and then
contracting Trump with this image of
politics, that's not actually right.
Real so.
Isn't that an interesting example of why
the 24 hour news cycle or whatever you
call Twitter now or 24 hour news cycle
sounds crazy, but we need somebody else.
This hyperspeed insanity of why it really,
it's,
it's a threat to our ability to think
clearly about things because the very
people who you hate it, eight
years ago, all these were not now.
I'm not saying it was warranted
than, yeah, I regret I will.
I don't know that I've
ever said this publicly.
I regret not voting for
Mccain in retrospect.
I think that we'd be in a very different
place right now. And I think he was,
I think he was the,
he may be the last decent man that we
had running for president at least for a
long time as a decent guy. Ron.
Oh, Ron. Okay, so all right.
That might've been a little bit
of hyperbole, but if you remember,
he always wanted to go,
hi. He made her come here.
High level mean he refused to go
with the Jeremiah Wright stuff.
He called off his campaign in the last
month because of the economic collapse.
Okay. So I'll, I'll modify that money
without commenting on Romney specifically.
Like I think by all, by all measures,
Mccain for whatever his flaws may be,
and maybe he was a little
more of a neocon than,
than I would care for her
or whatever else it is.
It's like if you don't think he was a
decent man who really loved his country,
like you're,
you're actually crazy.
And this goes to when you demonize people
to the nth degree who don't deserve
demonization,
then you get the real demon.
And I'm not even saying Trump is the real
demon, but the way they flip history.
So it's like you hated
him forever and you,
you want it to destroy this guy forever.
Now he hates your new demon cause
you're always finding new demons.
So now we got a new good guy
and it's like, that's not,
that's partly because we cannot remember
history anymore because we're slammed
with three day news stories that, you
know, I said it's 24 hour news cycle,
but it's really, it's, it's
more of like a three day thing.
We care for three days and then expunge,
you know,
and I think that that now is becoming
like the real threat right now.
Okay.
So final news story for you,
and this would be the one that really
has ruined everybody's Day, but
that's great. So there's,
so there's a big scandal.
We don't have a bruise
on his head anymore.
I'll hold the bottle of wine
there. But yeah, the, uh,
you're not gonna have wine
for this one and it's,
so basically there was a
big scandal in Pennsylvania.
There was a state attorney general report
that suggested that over the course of
30 years,
1000 children who've been molested by
Catholic priests and that these kit and
that these priests had then been around.
And then following on that,
there's a guy named Archbishop Vergano.
Uh, and uh, he was the people in Lindsay,
I believe,
to the United States and he came forward
with an 11 page letter in which she
accused essentially the entire Vatican
hierarchy of being complicit in covering
off trout molestation, child rape, uh,
and what he suggested was a
growing weed in his terms,
homosexual subculture in the church when
she means by which he meant that there
was there particular cardinals who had
been accused of actually used to do sing
seminarians and all of this sort of thing.
Yeah. Let's just pause for one second.
[inaudible] linked those two things,
but I don't mean to sound Glib here,
but how is this sort of new,
so it's only new in that he is accusing
Pope Francis of actively covering it up.
Oh, okay. So he's saying that
there's a cardinal McCarrick who was,
who was complicit,
who was apparently accused of child
molestation or at least molestation of
underage seminarians, basically.
Uh, and this and this guy,
artificial Degano said Pope
Francis not only knew about it,
he reinstated McCarrick embedded,
acted basically put the guy in in
silence and prayer and that Francis had
brought the guy back and made
him a public figure again,
it had done so with multiple
other similar figures. Uh,
and because Francis,
the accusation is soft on homosexuality
inside the Catholic Church,
that's his accusation,
but Ganos uh,
and then by extension soft on people who
had been molested seminarians and also
happened to be homosexual, uh,
or practicing homosexuality. So,
so I, uh, okay. So all right.
[inaudible] they conflated
here. So a couple of things
being completed. One is, uh,
people are suggesting that,
um,
the reason that this is all happening is
because anti gay feelings in the church
are leading people to go after Francis
or leading people to go after McCarrick.
I,
and that's a weird argument because really
what we should all be able to say is
that a few things can be true.
One,
there's no statistical linkage between
homosexuality and child molestation.
Right.
Obviously to that,
a disproportionate number of the people
who have been molested inside the
Catholic church had been young
boys. Yeah. Which is also true.
It's four out of five and three that any
pope who covers this crap up should be
criminally liable basically.
And the media, it's like
paternal, I mean, exactly.
And you know, this exist in pretty
much every major institution,
secular or religious.
There's always an attempt to cover up
sins inside that particular institution.
This is true for every religious
institution that I know about.
Pretty sure it's true for every
institution. Public schools,
like legitimately every
institution button.
So you tried to cover up
the whole, uh, you know,
trying to take out Bernie
thing that was driving.
So, the, so the, but the,
the part of this story,
the twist to the story where the good
part that's new is not only that for,
it's a Francis stayed silent, he's refused
to respond to any of the allegations.
Uh, it's, the allegation has been
backed by a bunch of other testimony.
Bishops are basically going to war with
one another for the first time in 500
years. Like they're openly criticizing
each other. Wow. And the, and I think the,
the most shocking thing is that the
media are running full scale editorials
attacking the quote unquote
ultra conservative wing
within the Catholic Church
for going after Francis.
So the same media that back in 2003
was going after John Paul two. Yeah.
And saying,
and benedict and saying these guys are
responsible for all of this and they
should,
now they're defending Francis specifically
because they think that this is a
conservative attempt to ask Frances
because Frances a liberal pub.
So, okay. So basically
the media is trying to,
he's because he's a little more
pro gay, so to speak, whatever that
all that middle environmentalist and
he's more of a selection in general legal
immigration and all that stuff.
Yeah.
So the media oddly is
trying to protect him, man.
I mean this again it goes to this thing
of like we are enemies will be our
friends the second we need them and
then we'll throw them out and what,
I mean this is just sounds
awful. It's awful. Yeah. I
mean it's like a 500 years.
It could cause a 500 years can schism in
the church like the worst schism in the
church since maybe the
Protestant reformation. Yeah.
Because there's like an entire wing of
the church because you can't impeach the
pope. There's entire,
we'll get the church going.
The Vatican hierarchy covered this stuff
up because they cover this stuff up and
now he's being defended by a bunch of
people who aren't real fond of Catholics
in general. Yeah. But somehow have
now found enthusiasm for Pope Francis.
If you were, if you were Catholic
and, and you were a real believer,
but obviously didn't stand
for any of this of course.
But let's just say you're the average
Catholic out there. Who's a good,
decent person.
You happen to be older believer,
I would assume the way you believe
in Judaism, it's okay. So let's say,
let's say you're that now Judaism, I know
it doesn't have a structure like that.
Yeah.
That's all I'm doing is any rabbi
[inaudible]. I mean, I don't know.
I'll see you in the Jewish community.
I don't know who Catholic
doctrine warranty.
You don't have papal
infallibility and Judaism. Yeah.
Any rabbi who complicit in the cover up
of child molestation should immediately
go to jail. Yeah. I mean like the, the,
I have no tolerance for this
kind of bullshit. And the,
and the fact that this is not only
being tolerated but forwarded by certain
members of the press is
an astonishing thing.
And it's the same people who are
getting spotlight an Oscar, right?
Five years ago. Right, right.
Because it was so important to uncover
all this stuff happening within the
church and now it's no guy hands off.
I mean,
France is really important figure and
the fact that all these people are
attacking him, we can't take it seriously
for political reasons. We have to,
we have to suggest that it's
just a hit job against Francis.
Do you think there's like sort of like,
this is just another extension of,
as we've,
over the last couple of years,
just watched all of these
institutions crumble.
Like we've watched
mainstream media crumble.
We're watching our political institutions,
I don't know that they're quite crumbling,
but they're, they're [inaudible],
they're teetering certainly.
But shifting in nature and also like
the legislative branch is basically
becoming a useless, nothing is
as worse as we're right as we're,
as we're handing everything
over to the king. Uh,
another good reason to
be for small government,
either classical liberal or
libertarian, etc. Um, but that,
that this with the church without,
without making it too specific
about these specific things,
that it's just another one of these
things that these giant institutions that
used to be able to control narrative
control gatekeeping and all of that,
they actually cannot withstand
things anymore. Sort of,
I mean this is where I've been sort of
critical at the Internet and the way
we're all behaving on there,
but like truth does find a way.
So then we watch these institutions try
to attack the people because the people
have a better essence of what the truth
is then be institutions or am I getting
something there?
And that's exactly right in the,
in the fact that it's the most shocking
performance by the press that I've seen,
including anything with regard to Trump
to shift to shift on a dime and start
going,
well you know what,
let's go check out these allegations of
child molestation cause we really liked
this pope. It's like, Whoa, that's,
that's, that's pretty amazing stuff.
And I'm talking not, I'm not
talking about the editorial boards,
I'm talking about objective news
coverage, objective news coverage. Yeah.
There was a headline in the New York
Times that said Pope Francis takes high
road as conservatives pounds,
man over allegations of covering up
sexual abuse of seminarians in, in mind.
First it's, it's, it's totally
wild. I mean, I think we,
this is just part and parcel with what
we've watched sort of happen to the New
York Times over the last couple
of years. I mean, you know,
I've said this many times,
but I,
I'm pretty sure the New York Times didn't
cover Bret Weinstein at evergreen once
in the pages of the paper, but did three
or four editorials about it. You know,
they,
they constantly do this type of thing
where it's like they're editorializing
their entire coverage often
by what they're not covering.
And so to watch this was
an important institution,
I think for a long time kind
of crumble like that. And I,
this gets us back to that story 20 this
gets us back to story one where now
you're going to bring in
people to actually, instead,
this is where when people say,
Dave, you attack the left too much.
You don't have to talk the right.
It's like the right,
this isn't about institutional
power anymore at some,
at some old Trump's the president,
I get it.
But like the left has all this
media power and all everything else,
and you're willingly bringing
in people that truly are racist.
Or if without calling these
people specifically racist, have,
have terrible ideas.
And you're saying this is,
this is part of what mainstream should be.
So you're mainstreaming what would
a really radical ideas. All righty.
Yes. Yeah. Got You. Got
You. There it is. Okay.
So submit your questions for me and for
Dave on Patrion and super chat right now.
We're going to take a quick break and
then we'll be right back with those
questions.
Oh Man.
Wow.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] whoa.
[inaudible]
okay,
well we're back at the Ben Shapiro report.
That's all right.
I'm hosting today because Dave is just
back and if you missed it earlier,
we went through all of the news.
So Dave is markedly more depressed
than he was an hour and a half ago,
which makes me happy since I'm a status.
So let's run a tight ship. By the way,
when I do the breaks in between
the interview in the live show,
it ends up being like,
I always say we'll be back in 30 seconds.
It's like seven minutes.
You were like, well come on.
I mean we've got to make money. So it's
fast and you move. That's exactly right.
So we've got patrion questions
and super chat questions.
So let's start with the
patriarch question. Dave,
do you think there's any turning back
from the politicization of literally
everything fun or is
this the new norm now?
I think for now it is the new norm and
I think that we have to get through this
and I think we can get through it. I'm
telling you, as I said to you an hour ago,
I spent the last month talking to
real people all over the place. Ray,
I would literally on the street,
like if I just saw it,
like if I was just standing there, I
just talked to, I was just talking to me,
but I really felt like I could be
a little more connected to people.
People don't want everything to be
politicized all the time. They don't want,
why do you watch sports? It's not for
politics. Why do you watch the Avengers?
It's not for politics. Why any most of
the things you do, it's not for politics.
And the fact that they've let this
creep into everything too. It's,
it's just another, and when I say day
it's like there's this a morphous thing.
I'm not a sports media. Yeah. And I don't
know that it's, it's cool. You know,
a fully, I think there is some level
of coordination in different ways,
but like I'm not saying there's like a
group of four or five guys sitting in a
room like how do we divide America and
destroy everything? Maybe there is,
I don't know,
but like this endless thing where we
just are going to hate each other all the
time. And this is why I've said it
before, but like this is why I truly,
truly believe,
I believe it now more than ever,
identity politics is the biggest
threat that a free society has and is
particularly our free society because
we've done the melting pot better than
anybody. We did a melting pot, we did
it right. We blended this thing right.
Everyone still wants to
come here for a better.
All these celebrities that always tweet,
they're going to leave.
Nobody ever leaves. And the same people
who will tell you what a racist, evil,
patriarchal, homophobic,
transphobic society America is.
They're the same people who want open
borders because they want apparently
everyone to come in and share in the Harz.
So I think it's truly, it is a threat.
But yes,
I think we will get past it.
And the reason I'm hopeful is because
when we look at all of the mainstream
media that's peddling
this stuff crumbling,
and we look at the amount of people
that are listening to long form
conversations and getting
what their ideas are. I mean,
when I go to these Peterson things and
people come up to me and say, you know, I,
I started watching your show and then
I saw Shapiro on there and Harris and
Peterson and blah blah blah.
And I started thinking about things
differently and then I bought Peterson's
book. And you know what, I
I stopped smoking weed or
yeah. Yeah. I'm not even
saying smoking weed is bad.
I know we have a difference of opinion
on the lines based on this stuff. Yeah.
So I really believe that
while you can't see it,
if you just look at that online tier,
that in reality,
I think there is something
incredibly good happening.
Okay. So here's the super chat
question for you. Uh, let's see. Um,
it says love the do this one's
interesting. Love the two of you.
You both converted as socialist
into a libertarian conservative,
awful about Russian Shapiro.
Will you bake Ruben a wedding cake?
Okay, so my answer is I'm married
already, right? But an adverse,
or I buy my anniversary last week and
anniversary cake would have been nice.
Right? So I, so the answer is no.
And the reason I won't is because
it's a religious Jew. I, yeah.
I do not participate in activities
that I believe are sinful. But again,
we live in a free country
and Dave knows this.
He doesn't have to care
what I think about sin.
And as long as I'm not bothering Dave,
I don't see why it's a problem. Yeah,
it will. I will. I did. Does Dave have
a husband? Yeah. I mean like, okay.
And Are we friends?
Yeah.
And Are we gonna go out to dinner
sometime in the near future? Yeah.
But there's a difference between me just
being friends with Dave and me actively
participating in an event that
I feel is religiously sinful.
And I think this is how most religious
Christians in most religious Jews feel.
And while at awkward, yeah, we're
still friends in spite of it,
which is why we're friends, friends, in
spite of it, then it'd be a bad thing
when I, when I did your interview show,
which by the way, I mean, yeah, you Jack,
the idea of an interview show front
of me, it's all right. It's true,
but nobody has done it before me.
Um, but what you said that to me in,
and I truly mean this, like if you
think what I'm doing is sinful, like I,
I know it sounds Glib, but
I don't care. I you is,
you don't have to care, right. Free
Country, right? Like that's the thing.
And it's like, look, look, there is,
of course someone's going to go,
well wait a minute.
If you really think his marriage is
sinful are saying, of course they'll,
they'll may be a place that in the nature
of our friendship maybe that we can't
quite get to,
that I would be able to get to with
someone that didn't think for sure.
That is very possible. And, and
it, and it goes both ways, right?
Like I then look at you and I go,
well why
that's a kid.
You don't want me teaching your kid about
the nature of family perhaps, right?
I mean like, like there are
some lead, but I just put,
you're probably a pretty good dad.
Like, you know what I mean? Like we,
but why is it that we're able to do this?
And most people can't do this? That's
what I'm curious about. Hold on.
And we can have our own lives.
I mean that's, that's real.
And I think part of friendship by the
way is that like we go home at night and
we just have our own lives. Yeah.
I'm not married to you. Right.
And like that's like my wife and
I have to agree on these issues.
You and I don't have to agree on these
issues in order for us to share a common
space together.
And that's really the important thing
that your wife and you have to agree on
these, on all of these
issues or just the sort of,
the more foundational and
the foundational ones.
But I do think that how you raise your
kids religiously and with regards to
things like sexual morality does
actually have to be at the root of,
of how you teach your kids.
So if you have deep,
if you have deep divisions with your
spouse on these issues, I think that,
and you're looking to
build a family anyway,
then I think that these are issues where
building on a bad foundation is a bad
move. So let me, okay, so if you
wouldn't bake me a cake, that's okay.
Now because it's 50,
50,
I can't bake you a cake
with David's trouble chef.
And He would've done it coaching the
whole, wow. Now I feel bad for you.
You got me this clothes.
Putting that aside, you can't
have any bids. Kosher cake.
Now, um, if we were having an
anniversary party, would you come?
If I was inviting all the crew that we
all know and we were just an anniversary
party,
we're just having a party and a,
and I'll even throw in some kosher food
for you to make sure you don't have to
bring your own know.
I'd have to think about it.
I'd have to think about
it in the same way.
That's interesting to me cause
that's, that's a different
thing. Well, not really,
because again, it's if you're
a religious person, and again,
take it from the religious perspective
that from the religious perspective,
the question is,
are you glorifying something that you
think is sinful substituted party for
something that you think was originally
sinful? Can you participate in that?
So from a religious point of view, that's
an actual serious moral question. Yeah.
What I go out to dinner with
you, the answer is yes, right?
Because that's not actually like,
let's celebrate something that I
feel that you're doing is sinful.
But I'd have to, I'd have to
think about that one. I'm,
and I'm being in a perfectly straight
forward as possible. I want you to see,
that's so interesting to me cause
it's like if I threw a regular party,
just we were just going to a party
at my house and all the guys that's
[inaudible] like I bake you a cake,
but it had nothing to do with the gay
wedding and I would go to a party with you
that has nothing to do with gay men.
Would you make me a regular cake?
Could I just have a Thursday?
Sure I'd give you my baking sucks.
I'll just buy you one.
I want you to Shepherd's gate like Shapiro
cake and then I'm going to write it.
Then once I get a piece of crap,
I mean, it's not gonna be good,
but it's that it'll be there. All right.
Let's see. There's a lot there were,
you know what, this is what we'll keep
talking about forever and it's all right.
Exactly. All right. Let's
see. Um, so Ben, huge fan.
Why do Asians overwhelmingly support the
left in spite of their cultural values
and how do we change this?
Also,
how are you explaining each of
your kids why it's wrong to lie?
Are you using religion or reason? Uh,
so the, uh, on the first question,
why do Asians overwhelmingly
support the left?
I think that there is a misperception
that is bolstered by a republican
inability to talk about issues of race,
which is that you have to overcome the,
the basic presumption that
Republicans are evil racists.
And once you get over that presumption,
then people tend to
vote more conservative,
but then his genes might vote for
their own economic interests. Right.
And for their own college
education interest. I mean,
it's the left that's trying to ban Asians
from higher education to places like
Harvard, but the right has a
reputation as being racist.
And it is not forwarded by intemperate
remarks from the president of the United
States on these sorts of issues.
And the right also, you know,
should be willing to ignorance.
I think that there's this
weird conversation about
race that goes something like
this. People on the left say there's been
historic racism in American society and
people in the right read that as what
you're saying is there's historic racism
in American society and that
means you want affirmative action.
And so people on the right goal,
I don't even want to talk about that.
And the people and let's say,
well,
you don't want to talk about
that because you're a racist.
Because what they read
the right saying is,
I don't want to talk about it
at all because you're a racist.
When the conversation really should go
like this left as there's historic racism
in American society and go, right.
And then the, and the law says,
and now I want affirmative
action. You say, nope.
And then you have a conversation
about the actual policy.
But we conflate the questions because
we're all reading each other's minds.
And that's a dangerous game.
Well,
it's interesting because one of the
things that people say to me all the time
when I, when I do public speaking
events, talk to people after,
they will always say, you know, I was,
I, the huge amount of people say to me,
I was a lefty. I was just like you, I, I
s then evolved sort of the way you did.
And I can't tell you the amount of
friends that I have that now think I'm a
racist because I believe in
low taxes or blah blah blah.
And it's like the way they've been able
to conflate policy with racism is crazy
because they think the
average lefty out there,
and I'm just doing something broad
for the purposes of a conversation,
thinks that if you say low taxes,
you mean you don't want to give money to
poor people. Now that is actually true,
but that doesn't mean it's racist.
You think that there are better ways to
help poor people than just taking money
from some and giving it to others.
So they've really,
there's an incredible trick
that they've pulled there.
That these are not racist. The amount
of conservative and Libertarian,
uh,
college things that I go to and all these
things and I never meet racist or I'm
meeting some pretty damn shady racist
because I can't figure out that they're
racist and they keep, they keep inviting
me. So, alright, let's see. Um, uh,
on that second question,
how am I explaining to my kids why it's
wrong to lie religion or reason? I mean,
the answer typically is both,
right?
You say that God doesn't want you to
lie because you are and, and Bait.
And why doesn't God want you to lie is
the reasonable question and the answers.
God doesn't want you
to lie because it is a,
is a fundamental disrespect of
another person as made in God's image.
I think that virtually all of Western
civilization is built on one verse in the
Bible,
that human beings are made in God's
image and from their springs in enormous
amounts of good.
There are things in religion that have
brought about an enormous amount of bad,
but that is one aspect of religion that
I don't think you can get to simply
through scientific materialism. But this
is a Sam Harris. We've had, this is,
this is the Sam you,
Sam Jordan wanted,
that's what it all whittles down to
that can science and reason in your own
consciousness to get you there at a,
at a human.
Speaking of which was a patron
of question four, it says, Dave,
did you find out what they, what the
dark enlightenment is? The, Oh, you know,
someone asked me about the
dark enlightenment once
on a Patrion feed and I,
I think maybe somebody sent me
some info. I honestly, I think,
I think basically the idea of
the dark enlightenment for,
for those who are sort of
unaware, is that what, what
you know,
um,
pinker will do is he'll basically say
all the good stuff that I liked from the
enlightenment,
the enlightenment and everything else
is the counter alignment and dark and
light man is basically, well, no Roussel
was part of the enlightenment to,
he just happened to suck.
And so that's it.
And so trying to look at the downsides
and the upsides of the enlightenment is
actually a worthwhile.
So this is sorta like, I
remember right before I left, um,
there were a couple people like really
attacking the enlightenment as this
racist movement.
So this is sort of that,
that, but also like the, there's a,
there's a perspective on the
enlightenment that basically says that the
enlightenments move toward
individual values and away from was,
was simultaneously a
move away from virtue.
So if you look at sort of
more ancient philosophy,
ancient philosophy says that your goal
as a human being is to act in accordance
with natural law, natural law being the
things that [inaudible] reason dictates.
Essentially. This is sort
of the Aristotelian, yeah,
natural law argument. I,
and then in the, in the sort of
modern period people say, well,
but everybody has a different
idea of what's good for them.
So this libertarian idea and so what
we need is limited institutions so that
people can do whatever they want.
And so the idea of the dark enlightenment
basically is that if you take that
libertarian ideal to its extreme where
there is no social fabric that combines
us anymore than you either end up with
sort of this atomism where everybody is
on their own.
There's no shared sense of,
of belonging and those who knows your
sense of values. And on the other hand,
if you believe that reason,
rules everything but that individual
human beings don't mean anything,
then marks is a part
of this enlightenment.
Ideal to our reason is the head and we,
all we have to do is reorganize society
along the lines that we see fit and we
can create a better man.
Right. So I mean the other side of the
enlightenment, right. I got it. So,
so you know that I obviously I mostly
believe in that libertarian idea
[inaudible] right.
So I believe in it within the prism of,
I think that's how human flourishing
and human freedom we'll expand the most.
Not,
I believe you have to be left basically
to your own ideas but I don't want to
live in Mad Max at the same time. And
I understand, right? This is where
this is restricting in critique,
right?
Patrick Deneen has a book
called why liberalism failed
and his basic critique is
that we aired too much on the side of
liberty without in a focus on the social
fabric that if you don't focus on the
social fabric, you don't focus on virtue.
You only focus on,
right.
While you end up with is a bunch of
people who are non virtuous who think
everything.
Is that right?
You know, it's funny. I mean, you know,
my thoughts on most of these political
issues and we just spent the last hour
and a half talking a lot about virtue
and a lot about the social fabric.
So whatever that is there for it,
that's where, that's where I'm at.
Okay. Here's a patriotic
question. Uh, let's see.
Uh hmm. Okay. What,
if any success could president Trump have
where the media would give him credit
without a backhand
dilution or anything else?
Do you think there's anything
Trump could do with the media?
Would give him credit?
Not really. I mean, they've
painted it. Look, they've
painted him as Hitler. I mean,
I, the first video that I did
the day after the election,
sitting in my backyard,
I said, you know, the risk here is that,
and I was even saying
this before the election,
if you keep calling someone Hitler,
you can never acknowledged when anything
is good and that that will keep pushing
you further one way and potentially
pushing the other person the other way.
Or at least the supporters that
you, because you can't be like, oh,
well the economy's doing well, good
for Hitler. You know what I mean?
Like everything that you do that's
good is actually worse for you. Right.
Actually evil. And this is also where you
get this sort of a guy who I, you know,
I agreed with for most of my life
why now have some disagreements with,
but I had nothing but respect
for Bill Maher. You know,
a couple of months ago when
he was talking, you know,
cause he has real Trump
derangement syndrome and he
was saying this thing about
how if we, if the economy has to fail to
get rid of this guy, that's what we need.
And it's like,
yeah,
that's easy to say when you probably
have a hundred million bucks and I'm not,
I love Bill Maher and I hope he'll sit
in this seat one day and I'll be there.
And you know, yeah, but you
were on a show not too long ago,
but, but I don't want to be in a position
where you root for the failure of the
country because you want the failure
of this one man. If he, if he failed,
you know, Sam did a piece right after
the election. As much as Sam hates Trump,
he said, look, now he's
the pilot of the plane,
so if you want the plane to crash
while you're on it, so that, that,
that ain't great.
Right.
So I would say there's probably nothing
that they would really ever give him
credit for.
But I think at the same time what they
create is most people in this country two
years into a Trump presidency,
if you remove the tweets and the Co,
like if you remove, just like the generic
sort of screaming thing all the time.
Yeah. Well what actually is happening,
the economy is still pretty good.
Like we're not, does anyone think Trump's
going to start in nation building?
I actually think some of
our alliances are stronger.
Even everyone else says they're weaker.
I think some of the trade stuff
actually could start working our,
in our advantage. I don't,
I don't know exactly,
but I don't think there's anything
that they could really, you can't,
I mean I think you probably mostly agree
with that. I definitely agree with that.
Okay. So I won't, I won't ask you this
one cause I think that's a good question.
Is from your a super chat. Yeah. So
talk about the art and the studio.
What's the new art? Oh, I'm glad that
came up. So a, a spectacular artist,
her name is right there.
Uh, Kaitlyn rose, Janet, uh,
painted this painting that's behind you.
And then the painting that's behind
me is sort of inspired from that.
And one of the things that she did,
she knows how much I love coffee.
So you can see sort of the
texture, the texture, right. Minor.
That's actual coffee grinds
that are in there. Um,
I think her website is Kaitlyn
rose, c a y l I n rows, janet.com.
And she's done like, there's tons of
artwork in my house that, that she's done.
We have this huge millennium park claim.
What coffee do you like?
What's your call? Do you have
a coffee? Well, I have a,
I do French press and I grinded in the
morning and the whole thing. Yeah. What,
what do you do? Yeah. I mean I
haven't expressed it, but that's,
that's really fair to guess. I don't
find this press with that. I could see,
I could see you drinking
Keurig cause you will.
Cause you're saying you wouldn't
put the effort into that.
I didn't drink coffee until
like a month ago. Oh wait,
you've been talking this fast for all
these years without a goat cheese and I
was getting no sleep one week and I had
coffee in my show is marketing and I was
like, okay, well then I guess I have to
check myself to cocaine. This is possible.
And I were, even though you won't make me
a cake, I will brew you a cup of coffee.
I appreciate it. Thank you man.
That's all I'm asking from you. Also,
leave me alone if I don't want
are two things. By the way,
I equate quick note on that.
I would also mention that like in Judaism,
it's not just like gay marriage
that's off limits. It's intermarriage.
That's off limit.
So if a member of my family were to
intermarry like marry somebody who's not
Jewish, I wouldn't go to the
wedding. Realize it. Yeah. All right.
This is like an issue.
So even if that we,
let's say it was your sister for example.
Um,
even though I know she just got married
and I met the guy who does that, right.
Nice guy. Um, even if that would do
irreparable damage with your sister.
Well, you're the in, in,
in know my view, the,
the irreparable damage is being done by
the fact that like if you're brought up
in a certain,
with a certain sense of values and rules
and then you abandon those values and
rules, then uh, you know, that's, that's
an irreverent, it's so interesting, right?
I,
I really intellectually,
I really kind of understand that and I
think that we are living in a society
that's because of the loss
of what clarity is where we,
that's part of why the
fraying is happening.
But it's like when we went out to dinner
that IDW night and we were at that
steak house and we all had these, Joe
got this like, you know, giant Tomahawk.
That was for two people.
He hated himself of course.
And Jordan had like the biggest
steak I've ever seen and uh,
Eric and I split this porter house and
it was so freaking delicious and you
brought your dinner right cause you're
kosher so you're obviously not gonna be
there and you wouldn't even need
on their plates and all that.
And I respect you making that decision
for yourself. I, I, I truly do.
I truly do. And I have family
members who are closer. Yeah.
As a religious person. Yeah. There is a,
there is a constant conflict between
your role as a religious person and what
you may feel in your heart.
Right.
So the fact is that I want
to keep by everywhere. Yeah.
There are certain rules about like
when I'm supposed to wear a Yamaka,
like if I walk into a place and I'm not
obviously carrying my own lunch. Yeah.
It's actually a problem because people
might think the restaurant is kosher for
example now.
And then they're going to eat there
because they saw this famous orthodox Jews
walking into a non kosher restaurant.
So that's something that you have to take
into account is that how much are you
conveying that your religion approves of
a particular activity when you actually
engage in the particular activity and
that that applies to a wide variety of
them.
It's so interesting to me though
because when I came home that night,
I swear you can ask David after I
was like, I was sitting there and I,
I can Ben Bright, I think he brought a
burger. You're eating your burger and I'm,
I know how delicious this steak is.
And it's like, I really was like,
why would Ben deny
himself just this truly,
truly smell delicious delicious thing
book. But you do. And that it doesn't
because it's talking about holistic
lifestyle in which you make choices about
what you want to participate
in and what you don't,
but that doesn't change even necessarily
how you feel about the people who are
engaged in particular
activities is just saying like,
I as a religious person cannot
stamp within premature like that.
This is okay with me
as a religious person.
But that doesn't mean that I care
about you any less. For example,
or I would care about my sister any less.
Right.
If she did something that I didn't like
just in terms of importance. Uh,
I'm going to move the stake away.
I'm not going to force you to say I still,
I think I'll be able to get you to smoke
a joint at some point and I definitely
am going to be able to get
you say fuck on camera though.
I like your posts. Your so called the
last one is actually not that far a leap.
If, if I, I had a blue version of my
show we'd be on believable of my
show would be on Real Shapiro.
Perhaps some of the people we've been
talking to have some ideas for some new
shows and maybe there was something
already in the world would be pretty wild.
Yeah. Okay, so a couple of
more here. Let's see. Um, okay,
this is, this is a good
one. Super Chat question.
I'm sorry. I want to find all
the best ones here for it.
We're doing it live. Yeah, exactly.
I'm trying to read these. Okay,
so the ancient Greek proverb,
if you go to work,
you better finish it or you'll
leave it to your grandchildren,
which I don't think he's
actually from the ancient Greek.
You think we didn't finish the war of
ideas against Marxism in the Cold War,
and that is why we have a rise of
Marxism on college campuses today.
I'll let you feel their first.
I think that my basic answer would be yes,
we sort of let this stuff fester
as if it was the cool stuff,
but I don't know what the
completion of a war of ideas is.
Like you stamp things out to the
point that no one can speak of them.
That's not what we want. So, so it's
almost an unanswerable question.
I think Jonah Goldberg's answer
on this is basically correct,
which is that there's a human tendency
to buck against freedom and that human
tendency is why can't we
control the world around us?
Why can't we get together and
solve all of our problems?
Why is it that what free markets
are counterintuitive? The idea,
if you leave everybody alone,
your life is going to be better,
is really good for intuitive.
Usually the idea is if I can
control everybody around me,
then my life will be better cause I can
get them to do all the things I want
them to do. I don't want
to control anybody, right?
But I want my little piece of the Pie
and I'm going to do good work here.
But that's it. But that's it. That's
a cultivated idea most as a child,
right?
Or like when I look at my children,
my children want to control everything
around them, right? Including me and what,
and if you believe that
if we all get together,
we can build this giant edifice together.
Why can't you just get on board?
Just get onboard. Then Marxism has
a certain kind of particular draw.
Especially when you look at the fact
that they're rich people that are poor
people. When you say
to people, well, right,
they're going to be some rich
people in some poor people,
but overall we're getting richer.
That is more counterintuitive than
why can I just steal that guy's money?
Put it in my pocket and I'm better off.
And so I don't think that Marxism can
never be fully stamped out. That said,
I think the conservative movement has
failed markedly to make good arguments
against Marxism and they've basically
made arguments on the basis of efficacy
rather than morality. They've said
basically Marxism, it's moral idea,
it just is bad and administration. And
I think Marxism is deeply immoral idea.
That's also terrible in administration.
So do you think that's also why guys
like like me and you get so much hate
because someone like me,
I'm, I was once something,
I had a certain set of ideas I've shown
you can escape and survive and now there
clearly is a massive movement behind that.
I mean I know it,
I know it is real or the amount of young
people that are waking up and are going
this thing that they're going to sh
jammed down your throat in college and in
high school is not good. It
is not real. It is not true.
And there aren't many examples of people
escaping. There was David Horowitz,
you know, 30 years ago or whatever,
but there's not very modern examples.
So that's why for the, for the, it's
not like I put out a lot of hate,
but I seem to get a lot of online hate.
And I think that's the reason
that I think partly for you it's,
it's similar to a different degree.
You
get it because you're willing to talk
to people like me and Sam and whoever
else.
So they're going the real hardcore people
that hate all that stuff don't want
you to do it,
even though they love you,
but they don't want you to do it
because they think that might be okay.
A little awkward. Gelati
exactly. Yeah, exactly. Okay.
So somebody wants you to do
a Trump impersonation for
the memes. Very important.
Oh. Um, what is it
do I do? I'm so as lady dies paper, I
don't even know what he does anymore.
You're fired. I Dunno. It's like, no,
I got to work on that stuff. Yeah.
Yeah. They, did you have any,
do you do any good impersonations?
You don't get good impression?
Uh, not I, you know what,
I'll come back with some DC.
I used to do a great Cosby impression,
but then he became the greatest
Syria naked. Naked. Do you'll sleep wake
of the Trump glut cake. Will the children
okay. Close enough. Close enough. There's,
there's only so much we can do here. Uh,
it says we put [inaudible] him
is going to go south so fast.
Hi Ben. In Dave, can you
define what rights are?
I think there's a disconnect between the
left and the right on what rights are.
Well, I believe you
are, you are born free.
You have the right to end in this country.
You have the right to life,
liberty and the pursuit of happiness.
And then the bill of rights lays
out what your other rights are.
The government has to protect those
rights. It did not give you those rights.
And I think that's the
most important thing.
The government did not give me my freedom.
The government can take away my freedom,
but he did not give it to me.
So we have rights that are very
clearly laid out. And again,
this is why I don't want big government,
big government in every way
will trample on those rights.
We've a beautiful system of rights,
free speech, the right to bear arms,
the right to privacy, all of those things.
These are incredibly powerful things,
but it's not because the right,
the government gave those rights to us.
It's protecting what I think.
So I know this is where conservatives
usually would say these are God given
rights.
I think you can just say they're there.
They're huge innately human rights
that you, you are as a human being.
It is your birthright.
You are born free.
Can someone grab you right out of the uh,
out of the womb and put you in jail?
Yes. But you were born
free. I think that's how I,
you said this,
the basic Locky and argument for,
for the philosophers in the room is that
basically you are born with particular
rights and these rights adhere to you
by virtue of you not having to get
something from someone else.
So you have a right to speak free because
that's not an imposition on anybody
else.
Right.
And negative rate versus a positive rate
as the typical language that is used.
Conservatives believe in negative rights.
People on the left believe
in positive rights.
This would be like the right to education
where you can take to the sky that you
have right to education. But unless you're
actually forcing a teacher to teach,
right, then there's no right, right.
The same thing, right to housing,
right to healthcare.
The left is very big into the clarion.
Good.
I believe you were right though.
Now we got him started on the impressions
and it's not going to stop it. Yes,
that's right.
So the,
so the idea there is that in a state
of nature where no one else is around,
you have these particular rights.
You have the right to make it to,
to gotten labor. You have the
right to, to control your labor.
You have the right to speak freely,
have the right to free assembly
to worship God how you want.
You have the right to do all of these
things because you're not imposing on
anybody else in the minute that
you're imposing on anybody else.
It's no longer right. So the baking
cake example is actually a good one.
There are folks on the left who say you
have a right to go into somebody's shop
in demanded service from them.
The answer is you don't have a right
to go into somebody's shop and Amanda
Service from them. Maybe you'd
prefer if they give you that service.
Maybe it's smarter if they
give you that service.
Maybe it's more moral if
they give you that service,
but you don't have the right to
go and demand service from anyone,
from anyone else because rights are
things that I am not demanding from you.
Then flip side of that is duties,
which is because you have a right to life.
I have a,
I have a duty not to kill you,
but I would have that duty not to kill
you regardless of whatever you call that.
Right. Okay, so while you were gone,
apparently there are a bunch of people
who have been asking about whether you
are indeed funded by then a ferry is
evil, terrible Koch brothers. Oh Lord.
So let's give you the opportunity to
answer why you were in the pay of the
shekel masters. Right. All right.
First off, well, if anyone
wants to know if this thing
is, I did it or not, I think,
there you go. Okay. I'm
glad you asked actually.
Cause this is just endless
dribble that is, you know,
this is partly one of the things
about just online nonsense.
It's like you could spend
all day defending yourself
about untrue claims and the
attacks that we get in personally attacks
and a trike often [inaudible] Sam,
when I had him on last
time a couple months ago,
he said for the two years that
he was under endless assault,
he almost views all his defense as wasted
time because often, nope. The truth,
the truth will set you
free. It'll, it'll, um,
it's the right thing, the
truth. But often if you're,
if you're debating against
or your protagonists are
attackers don't care about
truth, then you're just feeding
them by giving them anything.
You're just feeding more insanity,
which is why I haven't, I think I've,
maybe I've even addressed this public. I'm
not even sure. Okay. So here's the deal.
And I'd been completely transparent about
this the entire time. It's so stupid.
So learn liberty, which is they
produce one show of ours a month.
They've given us incredible professors
like Deirdre mccloskey and Randy Barnett
and Steve Davies and Shawn
Hopwood and people from all.
And Fatty is Russell people
from all over the political map.
They produced one show a month.
They give us a list of professors.
I can pick any of them and if I don't
like any of them I can pick anyone else.
They've given us people
all over the political map.
They sponsored our episode with
Phil to Franco, the youtuber.
They had never even met him or had any
interaction with him. They just liked him.
So I said,
learn liberty at the top.
This episode is brought to you by learn
liberty or our friends that you learn
liberty or whatever.
And then they donated,
they were going to give him a little
bit of money. He didn't even want it.
They donated it to a, to a
cause that he cares about. Um,
so I think what has happened here
is that learn liberty is a, uh,
subsidiary or in partnership with
Institute for Humane Studies,
which I think is through George Mason
University. And I believe that David Koch,
one of the Koch Brothers is on the board
there and must give some money to it.
I know for a fact that the person
who has funded our relationship,
my relationship with learn
liberty isn't anonymous woman.
And I know that because they told me that
she's anonymous and that it's a woman
and I personally wrote
her a thank you note.
I want to be 100%
spectacularly crystal clear.
They have had no control over our content.
I ask whatever questions I want.
We never edit for content.
We did once in my hundreds of interviews.
It was with a celebrity for a reason
that is completely irrelevant and not
important. They have never
told me anything to say. They,
there is nothing. There is literally
nothing untoward here. And I've,
and I've always, I always start the
episode by saying we're funded or were,
we're in partnership with learn liberty.
So we're funded by learn liberty
for that one episode. Anyway.
This is just endless dribble. And I,
it's almost like you can see I'm sort of,
yeah, it's like I don't even want to
talk about it cause it's like this is all
bullshit. This is all
distracting bullshit. And it's
like that's all nonsense.
And the amount that we get from them
by the way pales in comparison to,
to what we're trying to build on Patrion
and everything else. So it's like, no,
no one has ever told me to say anything.
No one has even ever
asked me to say anything.
I've never had contact with the cokes.
No one has ever said anything.
And by the way,
I would love to interview the cokes.
I would have literally no problem. The
Cokes Fund, um, the, the Cokes Fund, uh,
you know,
Lincoln Center and I think they put money
towards PBS and all sorts of actual,
yeah. So like I don't have
a problem with any of that.
So just to be crystal clear for anyone
listening to this or for any of these
people that just relentlessly
hate me or whatever,
I am not funded by the Koch brothers.
That's what you're saying is
you're funded by the Koch brothers.
[inaudible] there are millions,
there are millions of people in this
country who are, who donate to nonprofits.
And it's like if you
work with a nonprofit,
you might be in vendor in coots
and obviously control. It's just,
it's just so dumb. I hope we
cleaned that up, but you know,
I know it'll just give endless, here's,
here's another super chat question. Yeah.
Play prognosticator what our president
Trump's chances of reelection in 2020 I
would say basic short of some
sort of impeachment thing.
And I have to catch up on a little bit
of the news that you enlightened me on.
I would say basically pretty good if,
if the left's decision to go down the
road of identity politics and Social
Democrats, Socialists, Democrats, whatever
the hell they're called now. But the,
the Bernie Keith Ellison Wing,
which is an,
which is basically an
extremist wing of a party. Uh,
then they're going to be
in a lot of trouble if the,
if is there any blue dog Democrat left,
if that thing could come back,
a sensible liberal,
believe me,
I could vote for someone who's probably
a little more big government than I am.
I wish, and I talked about it for
years. I want my, I used to say my guys,
I wanted my side,
the left the Democrats to wake up.
There's no sign whatsoever that they're
going to wake up. Uh, potentially. Look,
if they get slammed in the midterms,
then maybe they wake up, but you,
you're predicting that they won't.
I suspect it's not going to be that
bad actually if you're a republican,
because I don't think there's anyone who
voted for Trump that suddenly looks at
the left and thinks that they're better,
but their numbers may just be depressed.
They may just not show up. And that's
always what happens in midterms.
And it's never good for the incumbent
presidents party and all that stuff.
But I suspect generally what they're
offering is, so it really is fringe.
And the only reason we don't think it's
fringe is because the mainstream media
jams it down our throat every day. And
if we can get that message out to people,
and I think you're a
particularly effective at it,
but we needed to also get to people
that won't listen to Ben Shapiro, right.
We need to get to people that'll
listen to me or, or whoever else,
people that listen to
Joe Rogan or whatever,
even though I know we all
have a lot of crossover. Uh,
if that message could get out there,
this thing that's being sold to you as
so obvious and good and the government
can fix everything and Blah, blah, blah,
if we can show them that is a fringe idea,
here are some better ways to
freedom, then I think, um,
we're forget Trump for a second.
I just think that that's a
much better path for a health.
He says,
I'm out in the political prognostication
business and so lost $10,000 for the
last election. By the way, I was
you the night of the election,
which I've told many people,
well actually I think we've
talked about it publicly,
but watching you that night,
you know
who's that?
It was entertaining.
It was like,
it was like being with like
eight different people try
to burst out upon. Yeah,
it was very wild. So yeah. You know, I'm,
I'm more skeptical at president Trump is
headed in a good path just because his
approval ratings are so low and there's
only a referendum on him once every four
years. So I think that, you know, 2018 is
shaping up pretty ugly for Republicans.
The turnout numbers don't look good or
Democrats are over representing pretty
much everywhere in the early elections.
Do I think it's going to be
like a 60 seat blowout? No,
but I think that there's a
good shot. Democrats went
about 35 seats in the house.
Again, I could be completely wrong
here. Right. So is the scariest. Yeah.
Part of that though, that lets, okay,
so let's say the Democrats
take back the house.
It's just endless investigations. I think
it's done for a couple of years. Also,
here's the thing,
president Trump is riding on excellent
news for the past couple of years.
He's at like 42% in the polls,
usually 43% in the polls.
He benefited number one from Gary Johnson
and Jill Stein winning a combined,
I think six,
7% of the vote in the last election cycle.
But also he has benefited now from a
great economy and no major foreign policy
crisis.
We're overdue for some sort of economic
downturn and there's one every eight to
10 years in the country. It's been since
2008. Uh, so I'm a little, you know, God,
God willing,
we avoid it and it just continues to
be strong because it'd be good for the
country,
but if they,
the, the idea that the
president is so in charge of,
he's not, he's not in charge of nearly
any of the economy. Yeah, it's, it's the,
I think the president can put a
serious damper on the economy,
but I don't think that the president can
be held responsible for the performance
of a particular economy.
Again, when people say Obama
was great for the economy,
it's like we'll sell.
Was the Republican congress great for
the economy because they were there since
2010 all of that said, you know, I,
I think Democrats are going
to turn out in droves in,
in 2020 in a way they didn't in 2016
the real story of 2016 to May was,
no one showed up to vote
for Hillary Clinton.
Like we're all focused on Trump because
he's the center of the universe. Right?
But the reality is that was a referendum
on Hillary, not a referendum on Trump.
Trump's approval rating
for absolutely stable.
They were always between 40 and 44%.
Hillary's bouncing around from 40
to 50 because people would say, oh,
well maybe she'll be good, and then
they'd look at her like, Oh God,
isn't that awful? And they
just wouldn't show up. Right.
You won fewer votes in the state of
what Donald Trump won fewer votes in the
state of Wisconsin than Mitt Romney did.
In 2012 Trump won the state of Wisconsin.
Romney lost the state of Wisconsin because
no one showed up to vote for Hillary
Clinton. I think Democratic turnout
in 2020 is going to be real high.
Trump has to win somewhere between 12
and 14 million additional votes between
2016 and 2020 in order to win because
George W had to win additional 10 million
votes to win, and he only lost by 500,000
in the popular vote. So how can that,
how can Republicans win? Democrats
can be awful. Right? I mean, that's,
that's what you're basically saying.
Yeah.
And so it's always a head
to head match up. Yeah.
If Democrats were on Kamala Harris,
Trump will win.
If Democrats were on Elizabeth Warren,
I think Trump probably lens, uh,
if they were on Kirsten Gillibrand
who will definitely one,
if they run Joe Biden,
I think it's an uphill run for
president Trump in the election. Yeah.
Bad is that you'd need to bring in this,
I don't know how old,
7,270 I'll be 78. Oh God. He'll be 78.
Trump will be 74 and the two of them will
just club each other with their canes.
Don't like the,
uh,
you know how many tennis balls we'll go
through running on the bottom of those
walkers. Yeah. Okay. Here's, here's one.
As a practicing Jew and as an atheist,
what are both of your thoughts on the
swing towards sexual freedom and sexual
freedom? Pre-Marriage? Has It negatively
effected longterm relationships?
Can I hit this one?
Yeah. Well first off I would say
this is why if, okay. Practicing.
So this is where I'm saying you're
a practicing Jew is a little,
it's hard to know what that means because
I would say you're on the sort of more
uh,
modern orthodox strict but strict side of
that and that your rights, you're okay.
Versus the version until I
was married. Yes. Right. Okay.
Okay. So you are all right.
Yeah.
Um,
so I would say this,
this is another reason where people
should basically be for gay marriage,
not from the libertarian perspective,
although of course that's,
I think the most honest perspective is
that the government shouldn't be in your
business. But also from
a, if you think, you know,
I think that when the Wright was really
fearmongering for many years about gays
and the Huckabee's and the evangelicals
were always, you know, and George W.
Bush because of Karl Rove,
you know,
used gay marriage as a wedge
issue and there were saying,
we'll look at the games.
They're all having all these sex and
they're doing all these drugs and about,
well guess what?
If you don't let people have the same
ability to love someone that they love,
if you don't let people enter the same
exact legal protections as everybody else,
then people are going to act out in
all sorts of ways. Sexually, drugs,
all sorts of things. I did all sorts of
things. I never thought I was going to,
I never really thought about
marriage. I just didn't. I,
I was closeted for a long time.
I think I was all sorts of
whacked out in in many ways.
But if you take a certain subset
of people and say to them,
you can't have the things that other
people have that will eventually maybe
allow you to have a family or whatever
else. And usually you can't have those,
well then every,
all your sex is going to be premarital.
So if your answer is well, because I
hear this, sometimes people will say,
well gaze, she just be, you can be gay
but just be celibate. You know that's one.
I mean it's ridiculous
and it's like you have to,
this is why gays are conservatives.
I think really it's the,
it's happened already so it
doesn't even really matter,
but it's like you should be for gay
marriage in a way that actually is for all
the other things. You're four because
you guys want a certain title, stability
and everything else for same sex marriage,
same sex marriage is the one that you
just made it even better than the,
the equal rights argument
cause equal rights argument.
You could easily say, well,
the role of marriage in between
a man and woman and man,
man is a little bit different just because
of natural child bearing and rearing
that hers the way why you guys didn't
make this argument before, right?
Like you weren't pounding the libertarian
argument for gay marriage eight years
ago.
I started hitting it in about 2012 2013
so that was probably a little bit before
most conservatives came around. But
generally libertarians, even worse,
I guess liberal real libertarian idea was
basically I want the government out of
everything. The government sucks
at everything. But as far as the,
the argument in favor
of same sex marriage,
if the argument is in favor of stable,
you know,
two person relationships
as opposed to wow,
promiscuity in every circumstance that
is going to be superior. But imagine,
imagine telling the subset of people,
I mean, imagine if the world was worse.
Gays were the majority and straights with
the room. And I said to you, you Ben,
you cannot marry a woman. Well now
you're going to do all sorts of things.
Like it just is. I hear,
I hear the argument.
It's interesting cause I think we
actually have a slight disagreement here.
If somebody were to say that
to me and my argument would be,
well I don't understand why I societal
institutions would make the decision for
me as to whether I should
live with one person or not.
Well if anybody's eye meaning
that like even if societies,
like as as a person who is a libertarian
on the government issue of marriage,
my vision is, well I go to my synagogue
and that provides me the Avo legitimacy.
I feel like I need with my spouse,
which is why I say like if gay people
want to get married in their church,
go for it. Like a toy. But
it's, but it's, you know, I,
I think it's hard to make the case that
promiscuity is deeply connected with
lack of same sex marriage.
I think that promiscuity is,
is connected with personal decision
making just because what you see is that
there's a riot, wild raise, rising
promiscuity in the straight committee.
Forget the gay community.
There's wild rise in rates of promise
Hillary on swiping right. And that far,
I guess you swipe left if you want it.
No idea, dude. It's a sweater and the,
I know it's all about a swipe. But if you
look at the rates of single motherhood,
for example, those who have been
on the rise since the 1960s.
And that's in a situation where straight
people are allowed to get married and
they have been allowed to get
married to historically. So the,
so correlating the institution of
marriage with, with promiscuity,
I think is a difficult argument to
make just statistically speaking.
But if the argument is that
that institutionalizing
marriage will make people
less promiscuous,
then I think that's actually a,
that's the best argument for same sex
marriage. I think that's out there.
If I were going to steal man
the same sex marriage argument,
that'd be the argument that you
need more stable relationships.
You need less instability.
You need people who feel that that's
actually a positive societal good to live
with one person as opposed to living
with a hundred other people. You know,
that's, that's, uh, you know, that,
that I think is the strongest argument.
So are you saying you're four
and forced monogamy? Oh Man,
man, that, that whole thing is so
stupid. It's so stupid. But, but it is,
it is true that a society that every
social science study ever done has shown
that when people live together
a long time before marriage,
they tend to get divorced at higher
rates than they would if they weren't,
if they just gotten married,
basically.
And the reason for that is I think
that if you, if you look at the,
at the research on passion and,
and sort of committed love,
they move in opposite directions
over the course of a relationship.
So when you first meet somebody,
your passion level is incredibly high and
your level of committed love, meaning,
you know,
I know this person really well,
I can count on this person is really low.
And then about six months in passionate
logos goes like that are committed love
goes like that, which is why if you've
married 10 years like I have, then,
you know, I'm, I'm really
passionate about my wife.
But to pretend that it's the same
level of like sexual attention. Yeah.
It's somebody that I'm dating as 10
years later with two kids. Of course,
that's not true.
That doesn't mean I have bad sex,
like I have a wonderful sex life,
but it's a different thing than it
was at the very beginning. Well,
if you correlate in your mind that
what's great about a relationship as a
passion level and that,
and then you lived together with
somebody for six months and then you get
married and then your passion
level decreases, you mistake the,
the correlation for the
causation, say, oh, it's marriage.
They caused the passion level to decline.
Not the fact that I've been living
with someone for awhile. Also,
the fact is that the reason people
aren't getting married in general and in
society where you're allowed to
get married, gay or straight,
I is because you don't want to rate.
That means that you're already got
an eye on the door in many cases.
And that's not a real flattering idea
for a lot of folks. So, you know, pre,
I think promiscuity is,
first of all,
I think that one of the worst lies
perpetrated against women is the women in
mentoree sex in exactly the same way,
which is absurd.
The idea that promiscuity is good
for women in the same way that it is,
quote unquote good for
men is fully insane.
I don't think it's good for
either from a moral perspective,
from a spiritual perspective,
from a health perspective,
but I think that the amount of damage
that is done spiritually to women, uh,
who are, who are promiscuous on
average, not for every individual.
It's a free country, do what
you want, but the, on average,
the amount of psychological damage that
is done to 16 year old girls who are
promiscuous is not nearly the same
amount of damage that it's wildly
disproportionate to
two men who are having,
right guys. Good. [inaudible]
highly correlative.
The guy in high school who's like banging
a lot of the cheerleaders doesn't,
it doesn't stick with him in
a sort of psychological I,
the suicide rates are not the same.
Yeah.
Among,
among young men who are promiscuous is
not even close to the suicide rate among
young, I mean leads to actual correlation
between earlier sex for young women
particularly, uh, and, and suicide
rates. And that's because women and men,
and we all used to know this,
but women and men treat sex differently
because women and men are not the same.
Yeah,
yeah. We should do a bit, well,
I want to do some big IDW panels in
general and maybe do some stuff live and I
think we're discussing all
sorts of stuff and all that,
but this would be a really rich topic
for sure because it does raise questions
as to like, what should we
promote as a society? You know,
forget about government regulation
and what, what's your merchants?
What are the basic, what are the basic
social institutions that are necessary?
Yeah.
And is it possible that we totally left
up relations between the sexes and the
future of longterm relationships
and marriage by separating
sex from marriage in
a really significant way, which, which
began really before even the 60s.
I mean there's a,
there's a decline in marriage that it
started before even the advent of the
sexual revolution per se.
Yeah.
Let's see, maybe a couple of more. Yeah.
Uh, okay. So, um, you're a good man.
I know you have a real job
and everything. Oh yeah. Yeah.
And I have to go write a bunch
of crap after this. So, um,
let's see it and then another, another
one we'll do, let's do the last one here.
So, okay. Um, hm.
Does a political scale with statism on
the left and anarchy on the ride this
from Patrion? What? Constitutional
law constitutionalism wise,
a bit right of center make more
sense than the traditional left,
right scale we use. Where does liberty
lie on the traditional left, right scale?
Um, I feel like we could do
something a little more exciting.
Okay. What's her letters? But I mean, why
don't we both do that one in 30 seconds?
It's something like a
little more excitable.
The 32nd answer is that
statism on the left,
the anarchy on the right is basically
the American political scale. The,
the European political scale is
nationalism versus international. Right.
And so,
and we're shifting towards that.
We are shifting toward
that and it's dangerous.
Like I think that the political skeleton
statism is on the left and anarchy is
on the right. Uh, I think that
that's, that is a better scale.
I think it's a more accurate scale. Yeah.
I don't mean to dismiss the question.
I'll do more than y'all do something on
this question on Patrion itself, but,
but for our big finish here, I feel like,
yeah, I already come out of Benjamin.
Okay, here we go. Here we
go. Them. Would you agree?
Would you agree with the idea
that classically speaking,
the left and the right have a
fundamental disagreement on human nature?
I Emam being inherently good or evil.
Keep up the great work. Yeah, we're okay.
Let's recommendation questions.
Do human nature. The first, let
me just tell you what I believe.
I believe people are basically good.
I believe you are.
You are born.
I think I pretty much buy
into Pinker's blank slate.
But I think you're basically born good.
There's something innately
human that you want to do good.
Doesn't mean we do good all the time.
We all do all sorts of things.
We lie and we cheat and
we do this and that. And,
and you have moments in your life where
we can all look back and go, Whoa,
you know, those couple of
years I was really doing some,
some self destructive shed or,
or some whatever it is. Um,
but I think there is something uniquely
human about wanting to do good.
It's how it's,
how human flourishing has existed.
It's not just because of the stuff that
we can empirically test and all that.
There was something
else about being human,
that little spark that you see in a baby's
eye when they know something's funny
and they can't even speak.
Like there is something else that is,
that is there, that is
human, that is good.
And I think it's sort of your job to
try to enhance that as much as possible.
At least I see that as my
job and I'm trying and I,
I will fail often and
I'll continue to fail. Um,
but I'm really trying to be the best
person that I can be while I am here.
And I think that comes from something
that's way before me that comes from
something that I can't prove
with tools here and measurements.
Like it's just something that is,
I think that's probably a little bit
of what your answer is, but maybe,
yeah. I mean, I do too. To
a lot of folks on the left.
The idea that human beings are inherently
good means that if we just unshackle
you from the bounds of society is
through the Russo idea that this was,
that your innate goodness will spring
forth and everything will be great.
Or from the Martin idea,
if you just change the economic system,
then we will all be inherently better
and we'll see each other as brothers as
opposed to enemies. So I am of
the kind of founding fathers idea,
which is basically a biblical idea,
which is that people are not angels
and not devils. Where human beings,
they have capacity for good.
We have capacity for evil. Uh,
while I love my two and a half
year old son, he's a nutcase and a,
and working in adult, he would be the
worst person in the world. He is, he,
you know,
he wants what he wants and he wants it
when he wants it and he doesn't care
about hitting people and you don't think
he's innately good or innately evil.
You think he just is as a human and
it's sort of your job as a parent.
This is what society's job
civilization and inculcating virtue.
That's your job as an adult.
And I think that the danger and the
belief that people are inherently good is
the idea if you just free them,
everything is okay.
Well freedom from political
institutions is one thing,
but freeing them from social fabric and
social institutions as a whole nother
thing.
So this is where I would say,
this is why I still consider myself a
classical liberal and not a libertarian
because I do think there is some role
for government and it's to protect those
things. And for me it's not even
about the role of government.
I think are libertarians really go
wrong is the suggestion that social
institutions are the cause
of all the world's evils.
That what we really need is
get rid of all knocked down,
all the churches knocked down all of the,
the places that are inculcating
virtue and [inaudible] will dictate.
Right. Of course. But, but
you know, somebody asked here
about debating arm broke.
I've invited yard on my program for
specifically this cause I ran. Oh,
are you guys doing it? I
know, I know he wants to do,
I mean I love to have him on that.
I'm happy to do it here. I know. Yeah.
I mean I think that we
disagree on less then.
I think that there's some
semantic games being played about,
about objectivism and what exactly is
self interest in all this other stuff.
Let's do, no, I'm happy to. I'm happy to
do that. But it's uh, but with that said,
I think that recognizing the human
beings are capable of evil is a deeply
important thing to recognizing that
you have to as an adult cultivate your
children in a way that they are
going to be good. So is that,
is that different though than what I said?
Because I believe we are born good but
it doesn't mean that evil evil he or or
that evil can generate through a
lot of people. I, yeah, I mean I,
I'm very reticent to use the language
we're born good cause I don't think that
babies are born with an innate, I
think I've born with a basic, basic,
innate moral sense,
but it's really basic and non cultivated.
And I think that if you had
a baby's mortality, if the,
if the world were run by babies,
we'd all be dead.
And not just because they're not
giving you should also because they're,
they're not moral,
they're not moral creatures.
They want what they
want when they want it.
I think that that's something
that has to be cultivated by,
by society and reason is something
that must be cultivated over time.
And that's why it's a constant attempt by
anyone who's good to try and say, okay,
what is impacting my reason here is
a passion that's impacting my reason.
Is it bias that's impacting my reason?
What is it that's,
that's making me unreasonable about
this thing and more reasonable,
we are hopefully the better we are as
human beings because we've actually fully
considered the ramifications of the,
of the policies that we're pursuing and
the actions that we're taking in our
daily lives. So I'm, I'm
very into the risks of the,
what we call an in Judaism, the gates of
her Ravi, you know, I mean, you know this,
right? There's the HR, I told
him there's the [inaudible],
there's kind of the good inclination
in the bat inclination and the idea in
Judaism is they're constantly
at war with one another. Uh,
and it's your job to try and strengthen
the eights or hot tub so that it
overcomes the HR. I think that's
the struggle of mankind. And it's a,
it's a Christian notion as well. I mean,
the idea of the, the fall, you know,
in sin is now embedded in
you. Uh, and even after,
after Jesus is coming about,
you still have to struggle with that.
Obviously used to struggle with the,
the Satan behind you basically. Um,
but I think that recognizing
the capacity for evil is,
is perhaps the first
step in becoming good.
And so this is why I'm extraordinarily
reticent to say man is naturally good.
I think man is naturally, uh, neither.
I think man is naturally driven
towards self interest and asking us and
tribalism and evil and man
is naturally driven to,
to fight that sort of stuff in,
in a variety of ways.
But it requires an act of will in
order to overcome all of those other
inclinations.
Yeah. And I can, I can get on
board all of that. And I stilled,
my fundamental belief is that
people are good, but you still,
you do have to cultivate it.
I think so. I think people in Western
society are good and I think that's,
that's an outgrowth of, of
several thousand years of
history. I think that if,
if we dropped you a lot of roommates,
I think if we dropped in the middle
of Afghanistan, you'd be pretty often,
I'd be probably very different
than I am right now. Uh,
as Peterson always says on this topic,
the devil's in the details. So, uh,
well I gotta tell you, man, first
off, thank you for doing this.
I know you're busy as hell and I'm, and
you know, you were the right guy to,
to sit down again. As I say, I'm
always happy to wreck your day. So,
um, you know, this, it's, I'm glad that
we also ended on this note because this,
that conversation that we just had I
think is what I think really matters.
And I think that's why people are showing,
you know,
thousands of people are
showing up to your live event.
Thousands of people are showing up to
these events that I'm doing with Peterson.
And by the way were were, I'll
do a live stream later, but we,
we just extended the tour into 2019
people don't want this endless bloodshed,
this mutually assured destruction.
And uh, I'll keep trying to,
and what is obvious is that headline of
the day is less important than the big
ideas.
And so trying to escape headline of the
day is sounds like it was a good idea
for you.
Yeah. All right, well thank you. Shapiro.
I'm going to go here for one second.
That's my camera right in my
studio over here. All right,
so here's what we're going to do.
I will do a,
we launched a whole bunch of stuff today,
so I finally got Dave rubin.com after
10 or 15 years of trying to even all new
website, we want you
to all new Patrion, uh,
this morning that I want to do a live
stream and talk to you guys about,
because I really want to start doing
some, uh, some new community building.
As you can see, we have a new set, we
have new graphics, we have new music.
I'm sure you're all commenting
on all of those things. Uh,
so I'll do a live stream probably in about
an hour or two a. So we'll post that.
And, uh, again,
thanks to a Shapiro over here and we'll
set up that thing with Brooke and a,
what else can I pump anything else out
for you? And go check on my podcast.
Ben Shapiro show. Have you heard
of the Ben Shapiro show? All right.
Thanks for watching everybody.
That was great.